people
are we live tell us if we're live and if
our audio sounds okay reject citizens we
need to know citizens that the audio
sounds okay that's the first order of
business always consider this your
participation in the census
someone's asking in the chat when does
it start it started now and we need to
hear from you guys in the live stream if
we can hear if we can be heard all right
hello is this thing on
i guess it's not working okay okay there
we go no koi today no koi was at comic
con himself
catch and cover left and right koi's
dead now i want i want the word to
spread just to ruin his career right now
yeah
super spreader koi
koi not only
koi went with it
gave it to keanu reeves
no more john wick press junket it's all
koi's yeah
um hey all right commons are rolling in
koi's not here today this is a good sign
it's a good sign actually people like
koi it's it's good it's good to because
of the fact that you know
um the fact the fact that uh adding koi
to here you want people to be like where
is the the new person we like him you
know so that's good that's a good sign
but if you want to leave i totally get
it
yeah but what's up jay sawyer uh damian
murray tommy bravo tofu khan but we're
gonna bring ko i'm working on taco rakoy
to come back this week he wants to like
stay a little distant just because he
was at an event but apparently he killed
it nikoi did a panel hall h hosted keanu
reeves berserker panel and apparently
did an excellent job according to his
words he said i did great no one even
cared about keanu the whole time they
just wanted to ask me questions about
coy's comic corner
all right um yeah i'm gonna start off
with this
sounds to me like marvel did not
actually disappoint which is good news
that's fantastic fantastic news i said
it many times in my video the other day
that i was like yeah i would love to be
wrong and i embrace being wrong in
situations like this and if anything i'd
rather contribute to being someone who
tells people to lower their expectations
that way when expectations are surpassed
it's rewarding so
i think i did an all right job you did i
don't care what anyone says but you did
let's shout out some people in the chat
right now he's here we got hottie gollum
you levy cade connors forrest brennaman
i jake if you guys can hit the like
that'd be great pandemic jones shout out
we saw raghu the rock is in the chat oh
dwight eight dimes hans eight you make
me wanna masturbate matthew levy or levy
welcome back john we missed you they
says i missed you too
john is back someone missed the whole
weekend with john no you didn't watch
any of the comic-con coverage but you're
here now this is technically still that
brazil loves you oh
thank you guys for being here oh my god
this is this is so there's so much is in
here this was a cool comic-con because
it actually felt like an exciting
comic-con again it did at least for
saturday it definitely did what are you
guys in the chat most excited for let us
know below and i see we got some super
chats thank you very much we'll we'll
get to them i promise then bp ch or or
whatever the letters were it says first
time in the live so welcome thank you
thank you for joining us no no someone
said [ __ ] john campia no no he's gonna
go live and you're all gonna switch over
to there in like 10 minutes i totally
get it
discount super chats for anybody who
takes their what they would have had for
john campbell and saves it for us yeah
that means a lot yes
no anything and everything there's a
stream labs link up at the top if you
want to uh you know if you want if
citizens want if you don't want to be
taxed yes by the state of the region
national nation
come over to our own offshore island
where there are no tax laws
but all right let's get to talking about
actual marvel goodies now that we are
here and we are established um yeah i do
i appreciate some people who see some
people in the chat i've been asking how
i'm doing as if i'm still recovering
from that plan you are suffering
admittedly i was a little bit more
emotional than i anticipated but that
was um that was a very if you guys
stayed for the discussion i was slowly
dissecting like why it was affecting me
so much
as it went on and uh i do think that
trailer is beautiful in fact it is i've
only seen it the one time uh when we
reacted to it because
even when i was this usu on comic con
days i'm like editing and slapping it
together admittedly it's not really
edited that much just because of the
fact of how
you know there's so much coming out yeah
but on that day uh for that particular
one i was like john can you plug in your
headphones and do this one with me
because even when i was editing it i'm
like [ __ ] man i'm crying again
it's happening right now i'm just trying
to edit this right now so i need you to
need to just be by my side right now
no it was good it was good it was like
it felt like like an older comic-con
like coverage like back in the days when
it was still like bumping and we were
both just yeah
well you see roberto one two one two in
the chat is saying definitely most
excited for guardians three and
guardians of the galaxy three was one
that i wasn't expecting for them to i
expected that they wouldn't reveal
anything online at least for in terms of
footage and stuff but to actually get
the confirmation about high evolutionary
and i heard uh what's his name chuck
chuck booty
i don't want to be an adult
yeah i'm an [ __ ] i got it wrong but i
heard he came out on stage in the high
evolutionary outfit yeah let me get a
visual aid going do they have the they
have it online we haven't seen it it is
online this will be a live reaction i
haven't seen it yet let's go close your
eyes
all right no cheating
no cheating g all right hold on let me
be able to see this because there's a
delay on the other monitor all right i'm
going to blow this guy up i'm trying to
say all right one
two
it's gonna be
smaller on your end yeah it's much
smaller on my end look off to the left
really quick there he is oh wow yeah
there he is
so purple
that purple mcu you gotta have a be
purple power stuff powers
yeah exactly well and hey peter quill
you know wheeled in the power stone raw
dog in the first movie
i hope that they actually make him uh
truly imposing and menacing you know
that if there's one like i liked
um
i really liked uh uh kurt russell as ego
and
ronan the accuser was it was fine
because whatever she did a good job
glowering totally serviceable but it
would be great that for jake for james
gunn to truly nail a villain you know
what i mean to truly nail down getting
someone who is actually like imposing
and stuff yeah because he's so good at
obviously
the family vibes and the fun and he's
good at giving these things like a good
amount of
like conflicting character nuance but
yeah it would be really cool for his
final installment he's been teasing like
it's the end of this story stories need
to end and to have like a truly great
and truly
you know impactful villain i think would
be so cool to see from him not that he's
had like bad villains in the past but
yeah like to get like
one of if he could do one of the best
mcu villains and be in that conversation
for this movie i think that would be
cool and i like i can't wait to see uh
uh chikuwuji's take on the character
cause even just like the little bits of
you know researching and kind of
familiarizing over the weekend and
leading up into this movie like it seems
like a really cool character to watch
him especially take on well people are
saying there's a video of it oh let's
find i'm a tad worried to play the video
on it so we've had that happen before
when we play a video and even though
it's all over youtube we've played
videos before and then suddenly the
stream is blocked and i hate when that
feeling happens it's just a terrible
feeling and it wouldn't be good for
anyone here right now but thank you for
everyone who just joined right now
um we but i'll watch the video on their
own time thank you for the compliment
alex wilson uh i do think werewolf by
night is definitely happening yeah
uh i'm excited for captain america new
world order aiden the best is asking in
the chat i know we got some super chats
props we'll get to them but in the best
right now is asking uh about captain
america new world order and
you know there is a
the first episode of falcon in the
winter soldier was titled new world
order and there is a comic run obviously
uh new world order which
if i'm not mistaken red skull
organization
uh lives on but then also you got
captain america steve rogers hydra
i don't think that's going to happen i
feel like you don't want to do that for
your first solo
um you know sam wilson-led captain
america film i feel like that'd just be
a little too much if anything they might
reserve that for we got two seasons of
what if confirmed so i feel like they've
reserved that specific plot line i think
they're gonna do it i just think they're
gonna wait to do it for
like something like what if uh but i'm
really excited to see if they can really
i just hope it's a hit honestly that's
my first feeling is this is there's a
lot riding on it it's the first time
anthony mackie is gonna be leads one
thing to lead a new series but this is
he's leading a show where he is or he is
the titular character captain america so
i'm really hoping
that audiences respond well to it and
that people
love it and can embrace it
that to me is the biggest obstacle to
overcome
um so yeah because i i like anthony
mackie a lot i accept him as a new
captain america
but admittedly admittedly you know the
first time you say captain america my
mind still goes to steve rogers so the
the thing that has to transition now is
after that film that our minds will
that most of our minds can trans you
know imagine it's like a bond transition
in a way
like yeah you gotta switch to it's a
passing of the battalion
yeah and it's like it's it's hard to do
and it's an interesting position because
it's it's motivated directly by the
story and it's not like weird or odd
it's not like oh we got to keep this
going so i guess we need a new captain
america yeah like i i really hope that
people turn out and and support that
because uh i feel like falcon in the
winter soldier gets kind of unduly lost
in the conversation because of some of
the issues they had with you know the
the villain plot and the stakes of the
flag smashers being kind of tampered
with uh so yeah i'm i'm very much
looking forward to it yeah i'm very much
looking forward to uh to black captain
yeah
that's right black falcon
um so yeah we are live right now someone
was asking if this is live can we see
what the super chats are right now just
because we got a few of them and i feel
always feel bad when we keep some people
waiting but yeah no daredevil that's
exciting news right there it is very
very excited for dart what do we got
here in the [ __ ] ten minutes late why
were you ten minutes late you shouldn't
have done it you're tardy go to the
office and get a slip that guy on the
right looks like jaby kowai who's that
[ __ ] jaby kawaii chavis kablabus i've
never liked that jaby kawaii i don't
know man addicon says i hate you guys
welcome to the chat thank you for
supporting by engaging with me yeah i
appreciate it thank you for your
engagement and uh your ire as well well
see i don't think the
jack in the chat is asking jack in the
chat check out the chat uh how was the
six how was the phase six reveal how
shocking was it i mean the the issue
that i think happened and you know i'll
get this out of the way right now and
i'm sure this question will probably
come come up again
is
the
the information leaked about those
titles on friday
with someone submitting it
it's like like what are the trade the
trademarks right yeah they submitted a
trademark office submission yeah they
they submitted it on friday
so i don't think they were actually
supposed to announce it on saturday
because i feel like if they were
originally going to announce it on
saturday they wouldn't have done it the
day before and and and submitted the
paperwork the day before i mean it's not
on i i don't know much about it i can't
be like that's that doesn't that's not
how it works so sure there's of course
um however the fact that that happened i
feel like that's what kind of pushed
them to do it i'm curious because this
is kind of weird to make you to have us
go so far ahead to the next phase phase
six but you did need a couple of things
that are like we need to bring some
stuff to comic-con that no one's heard
of yet yeah totally i'm curious now that
i've seen the full list or what i think
is the fullest because you know secret
wars and kang dynasty are on it but also
so is captain america new world order
marty versus saga and thunderbolts so
yeah part of me goes maybe like the the
the office was closed on saturday or
something
you know uh but yeah it's i
can't tell for sure this makes me go
okay maybe they were planning on
announcing it and this wasn't as big a
debacle or maybe it was like
we just so happened to be
getting these registered at the wrong
time at like the worst possible time
because
i honestly think if they were just doing
this for like way down the road that was
kind of a bad decision because knowing
for a weekend it was if anyone in that
trademark office was aware this was
going to happen yeah i think they wanted
to wait to reveal at d23 but hey
that's where we're at right now i mean
i'm glad that we know it and and i think
if anything it helps clarify the direct
because a lot of us have always you know
most of us have hey here's reforms in
chat what's up adam hey what's up dude
um adam's a great guy by the way
they're very helpful to us i'm gonna
text you back um the
what are we talking about
uh
the the uh trademark registration on the
names something to do with the avengers
obviously
oh yes yes yes i think i think um
that the fact that
we have had a lot of people discussing
like where's where's phase four
ultimately headed and what is the thing
that ties it all together and i think 99
i think most of us have have been like
it's they're doing multiverse stuff
they're probably going to collide
together in secret wars
you know so i think the big announcement
is that revealing that helps clarify the
direction especially since there's been
some discourse because even though i
highly doubt marvel is gonna do a one
for one adaptation of either kang
dynasty or secret wars they they
they don't do like they're not like
robert rodriguez with sin city you know
what i mean like or zack snyder with
with watchmen at least attempting to be
you know like they're
they they always take inspiration from
but they really make it their own and
and i think but but knowing the context
of what secret wars encompasses and
knowing the context of what king dynasty
encompasses that gives you a direction
okay so multiverses are going to be
coming together this is the that's it's
as simple as that and at least we know
that's what the direction's going to be
and we have a good understanding that
kang right now is the main big baddie
that we're focusing on yeah i feel like
at this point the way that they've done
it is now they have like they can't do a
direct adaptation of the comics anymore
because the movie multiverse is now so
well established that you would just go
so wait a minute are there's two
identical universes uh and so yeah i
feel like that's kind of a nice tool to
give you a clue as to what's going to be
involved but make it so that you don't
just know and can go spoil it
immediately alanis lucille asks in the
chat what projects do you want to see in
phase six i'm sure people have asked
this in the supers but i want to put
that to you guys and another person
i'm sorry i forgot who said it but
somebody said would deadpool 3 be in
phase 6. i bet that's a solid bet yes i
bet that's a solid but what do you guys
want to see in phase six because there's
a lot of open space spider-man um
so what do we got in the supers john
who's right here's the first one we got
pandemic jones is up thank you very much
love you buddy uh pandemic says what's
up boys proud citizen of the reject
nation here i love that grace see you
did a good work he loves the citizen
moniker
yeah i always love what marvel does so
loved the announcements especially
wakanda forever and daredevil what do
you guys expect at d23 much love d23
deadpool 3.
um the the two i'm putting my
money down for
deadpool 3.
um
i
i still wonder if we're gonna get an
x-men announcement i haven't really
believed that we're gonna get x-men but
we're gonna get something that's more
direct about mutants whether it is that
movie that we've heard rumors about
forever called the mutants which i
believe is what stan lee originally
wanted to call the x-men or we're gonna
and i think we're gonna get something
like that or maybe some solo announced
movie about some character but something
for sure to do with the mutants i think
we're gonna get the fantastic forecast
being revealed i think they really i
think they have that locked down now and
uh something about
they got so many slots on facebook it's
actually like kevin feig is a [ __ ]
genius you know you know because he gets
you excited about what they announced
and then he's like well we got all these
other blank spots here yeah you have no
idea what all this is a bunch of other
stuff it's so smart it's so smart
because then it gets your mind going and
gets you pumped to it's like he's
indirectly promoting d23 we're gonna get
the thunderbolts cast the character
lineup revealed there um i i believe i
don't i'm i'm curious what trailers will
probably get though you know that i
don't know what footage will get i
wonder if it would be more announcement
driven and less footage driven i feel
like we'd probably get something maybe
for ant-man and the wasp
just because that's
looming very big on the horizon and
that's something that's gonna be you
know even though that's the kick off of
phase five i feel like that's the one
that we have kind of the most solid
information on right now and the one
that they would want to start teasing as
you know phase four ends out you know
i think there's going to be more
personal endings than you know the big
overarching stuff so yeah i feel like
that and maybe like a look at guardians
or the marvels sure sure yeah all right
let's see who's next on this
i know we a lot of people are asking the
chat we are not going to react to that
ant-man wasp leaked phone footage of it
uh
we're not going to and we don't i don't
want to
personally see it until there's an
actual i don't want to see a regular
crappy because i mean i'm sure you guys
want when we do that video whenever the
trailer does come out i'm sure you're
going to want us to have the best
possible
genuine natural reaction to whatever it
is i mean i've heard it described to be
totally i've heard i've heard this
described like by so many people now
because of all the all the videos i've
i've seen about um the announcements
like i think i think uh cosmic wonder
heavy spoilers new rock stars they've
all done amazing videos you know what
they're going to do they're definitely
going to cut one of those medleys
together where it's like here's some
footage you've seen but here's a couple
of new things there's like five seconds
of a couple days hope it actually
started cameron dane scott if you had to
pick one would you like to see would you
like to see mcu films directed by
matthew vaughan bong jun host no piercer
wes anderson edgar wright
there's some bad blood there or daniels
um i feel like matthew vaughn when they
want to step in even though he did an
amazing job with the pg-13 driven x-men
first class movie i feel like when
marvel is actually starting to do
r-rated films yeah i think he would be a
fantastic director to bring on board who
fits within the mcu style yeah when they
really want to start mixing it up and
going crazy or like so deep and heavy
like when they brought i'm totally
blanking on her name uh the director of
the eternals i'm totally blanking out
chloe zhao yeah not chloe grace morales
hey maybe that would be fun to see carl
directs marvel i think when chloe zhao
is
like with her what they wanted her to do
you need someone when you get a type of
director like bong joon-ho who can make
the thrills like something like a snow
piercer you know but he would want to go
more commentary heavy and stuff like
weirdly i feel like he could do like a
cool captain america film i've
definitely yeah i would love to see that
i mean personally i feel like
i not just because i i've loved about
their movies but i feel like the daniels
would come up with something wild they
would have to have free reign to kind of
be themselves obviously but i feel like
they could come up with something that's
like as wild and bombastic as the kind
of introduction of a james gunn but on
crack like i feel like james gunn's
sensibility was something with guardians
where even though you were also getting
like universe expansion it was also like
whoa this this guy's sense of humor is
here and i feel like they could mesh
into the mcu or
i just want to give a shout out to go
watch patrick h willems uh what if wes
anderson directed x-men i feel like
we've already got the wes anderson
marvel movie through that all right cuts
cinema reviews how can you control this
john uh you know there we go there you
go all right we got it theory avengers
secret wars will take elements from the
original and the 2015 secret wars comics
and rhem will take beyonder's place in
the story that's an interesting point uh
i've heard a couple theories that
involve basically taking some of these
you know big arcing plots these big
trades and swapping out certain crucial
characters like some folks are
theorizing that perhaps instead of
secret wars culminating with a doctor
doom appearance maybe they'll swap that
out for kang and have kang create some
kind of battle world stand-in uh and so
maybe in this version yeah you could get
an rsm
you could have them retroactively making
the eternals more important that way i
mean eternals is it seems like it's
gonna have big effects on everything
moving forward but given the response to
that movie i feel like they could
certainly use that as a means of
building goodwill towards it you know
moving on yeah i mean i i think that
what marvel like we're all getting
focused on like time travel obviously
with kang you know like in king dynasty
as well
and then secret wars or the multiverse
i'm really curious and i'm wondering if
this is what phase seven is gonna be
about
because
you know phase one through three dealing
with the infinity stones and then face
uh
four through six yes the multiverse saga
and then i wonder if phase seven because
kevin feige said they got like 10 years
they got like 10 years mapped out and
then i wonder if like the phase seven
through nine will deal with the gods for
real you know really see how like these
afterlifes and all this [ __ ] really
connects the supernatural that's when
you get midnight suns and and all that
fun stuff and that's why you introduce
blade now
and you do some supernatural things and
that and then you go full on board
supernatural
come phase seven through nine yeah most
most definitely jb bonifacio bonifacio
it's a good name i like it it took me
seven viewings to not cry during the
black panther did you just sit there
refreshing it over and over again
i'm gonna make it this time
i'm gonna make it this time i appreciate
the super chat there jb and uh and uh ij
in the chat's asking if it's what
happened do you think marvel will change
the director uh
maybe i wonder if it's going to happen
yeah there's no announcements about it
and there's no armor wars magic there's
a lot of people in the chat have been
pointing up no armor wars mentioned so
they got to clarify that and probably
give some real details xx raptor xx do
you guys think daredevil will be tvma
daredevil do you guys think daredevil
will be tvma and how you think they will
tackle his catholicism because to me
that was very interesting to watch well
you know the fact that we have gods now
introduced in the mcu let's get some
jesus in here
and having like a complex confrontation
about faith and spirituality um i do
think that they will i wonder if they're
gonna they're gonna probably gonna want
to distinguish themselves from the
actual
um
you know netflix series it is
interesting they announced
being titled daredevil born again
because daredevil season three
daredevil born again i i read right
before season three came out and i
really loved that comic that graphic
novel very much
and it's it's there's no way the sh even
if even if disney plus makes it a tv ma
series
not even the netflix one went as hard as
the comic book
did because like in that one you know
karen page is like addicted to like some
hardcore drugs and [ __ ] it's it feels a
little bit more ruthless and now like
just in vibe and feeling in tone it's
just so much it's it's a little bit
harsher in the comic um
however uh i think for daredevil what
what i'm intrigued by is the fact that
it's 18 episodes because
when netflix had its shows out a lot of
people feel like daredevil's like like
absolutely perfect but you know when you
think about all the marvel shows that
are on netflix a lot of people would
feel that they dragged so there was
always like you could have cut this down
in like eight episodes the netflix thing
was cut it down and the disney plus
thing is making a couple yeah a couple
more episodes and now the daredevil ones
are like we got 18 episodes like wow
that's crazy it's it what's insane is
that you know there was all these
campaigns and stuff that we've done
videos here about about save
save daredevil
and then now um we're getting so much
daredevil there's like so much it's what
we kind of were expecting to happen with
andrew garfield perhaps uh when it came
to spider-man or when people were hoping
for that like let's get more of them in
here let's keep it going um but there's
nothing we're really hearing about that
as opposed to matt murdock which makes
sense because there's only one daredevil
versus having three live-action
spider-man
with matt murdock we're getting so much
of him you know he's he's he's supposed
to be appearing in echo um confirmed to
have 18 episodes
uh already confirmed to be appearing in
she-hulk he's in the spider-man freshman
year show you know i feel like they're i
mean the bigger the mcu gets i feel like
the more they'll just have you like
street-level people running around and i
feel like they're they're doing that
first and foremost with daredevil and as
much of a meme as it's become to me and
as much as i'm afraid that echo is just
gonna be a launch pad for being like
more daredevil yeah uh i am really
excited that they have embraced him to
such a degree
whoa mac's reviews in the chat is saying
that you guys know michael giaccino is
directing the mcu halloween special is
that a fact
let's google it i rarely hear of
composer turned director yeah and also
there's an mcu halloween special i'm so
excited
uh yeah i mean hey i mean jaquino like i
don't know i i it's you're you're in a
room with the screen in the booth and
you're composing a lot but he's always
you know doing big movies i bet he's got
a lot of big ideas well jdog36 that's an
interesting question to bring up the
chat because you're saying curious if
they'll bring back bullseye i hope they
keep that same grittiness that the
netflix version did yeah that's a good
question because of the fact that
um
the season three ended with a
cliffhanger that bull's eye is still
alive and it seemed like they were
really teasing that he's gonna become
like completely bullseye by the end of
it but i imagine they might just
kind of do their own thing okay so he is
directing it that's pretty crazy
maybe this will be werewolf by night
what an interesting thing he's worked
with a bunch of directors by now really
really close collaboration so i'm sure
he'll do a sure do a good job
all right john take it away what's the
next one we've got fear loathing in
general i always appreciate your name i
love i heart being a reject citizen
rejects citizens that's right i hate the
taxes uh so we don't control that uh how
do you feel about mcu's reactionary way
of mapping the next phases plans or fans
what's best you know this is the thing
i don't i know that they have to know
that everyone's talking about phase four
they're like oh phase four is aimless
but the more i've
looking at what they announced here and
then looking back at phase four so far i
feel like
there's an interplay of both and right
now i'm sitting in a position where to
me it reads as okay they looked at the
original phase and realized that phase
one of the infinity saga was kind of
weighed down by a setup and
interconnectivity that was very overt
and in phase four i feel like
we got mentioned on the campia show and
there's like five people who just said
this what
kevin's been very nice to us and campy
is a friend of mine someone sent us a
clip if he didn't live like so far away
i'd be like championing to go back on
his on his live show and if it wouldn't
be a nightmare trying to pull the clip
up here
but yeah looking at phase 4 right now it
feels to me like the interconnectivity
is just in that each movie has like a
piece of context it adds to the overall
situation right that is going to get
worse progressively and i actually kind
of appreciate that so um
to me these announcements as of this
weekend don't feel like them going uh we
gotta
you know make sure everybody knows that
there's you know like a structure and
stuff because i feel like they would
have given us more of phase six if that
was the case
um
maybe but yeah i i don't know i feel
like there's
they've gotten a lot better over time at
balancing
the fan interaction with what they do
with you know their vision and the only
thing i would wish they would stop doing
right now is trying to cut things down
because eternals didn't do great yeah i
mean that's
that's the funny part about like you
feel like the movies are shorter but
then you got something like daredevil
being announced which again 18 episodes
that seems like an awful lot are they
gonna be like 45 minutes they're gonna
be 22 22 minutes episodes with
commercial breaks it's gonna be like a
lighthearted daredevil it's gonna be
like a sitcom about matt murdock
practicing law it's gonna be what i've
always wanted uh yeah i i think i think
this has always been a plan and i'm not
sure i wouldn't call it reactionary what
this experience is you know and no this
felt like the revealing of of like okay
i didn't know what the plan was at first
but now i'm getting a sense for it
um let me see here which is good
geom films in the chat george what's
going on buddy you are killing it
everyone stop what you're doing open a
second table subscribe like loki season
2 as disney fan is saying i'm very much
excited for it's like we're going to get
so much kang implementation and i'm
surprised no one's really been talking
about dr doom because
i do believe that rumor's been around
since before they even started shooting
black panther wakanda forever that
doctor doom will appear
in in in black panther in some way
whether he is in a post-credit scene or
they or they evidently
allude
to
um
if they evidently allude to doctor doom
where there be live barrier yeah they'll
just like drive through let virio
they're like someone someone told namor
about it or some [ __ ] i don't know
something that alludes to the fact dr
doom is here
and i you know because i think if you're
gonna do secret wars
you know it's like you have king dynasty
and i feel like it'd be too repetitive
if it was just you know infinity war end
game first one thanos movie thanos wins
second one avengers wins and they beat
they beat king so i think
kang's story
will be primarily wrapped up in in king
dynasty king dynasty and we're going to
be getting little hints or clues or
teases of doctor doom and then he's
going to be the head honcho of secret
wars and so what will really distinguish
these three phases versus the first
three as as opposed to just building up
to one primary villain you're actually
building up to two and you're going to
find out one is bigger than the other
yeah
yeah
yeah so that's just where i'm getting at
and i saw that doctor doom leaked photo
i don't think that's a real phone i
personally don't think that's a real
photo i think i think it is a photoshop
there was stuff pointing towards like uh
that just made it really seems
like fake concept art but uh oh sorry i
forgot it's all good oh yeah that's so
satisfying i see people bringing up that
[ __ ] deck yeah i think they should make
doctor doom funny jd definitely make
them all funny yeah
right make taika waititi direct
avengers secret wars
yeah yeah yeah yeah make everyone happy
get some improv heavy actor to be doctor
doom get jason siegel to play doctor
doom bobby ketzel quaddle
if doom ain't the villain i should have
saved my doom thoughts for this super
chat it's a perfect segue it's all right
bobby if this was time travel to your
question we did it like jeopardy yes
i'll give the answer first but yeah i
mean that would be really cool and and
yeah if they do it in such a way where
it's like you know
these villains you know kang and doom
they have their nuances and their ways
in which they ride the moral gray and i
feel like if they can lean further into
that for a one-two punch as well would
be p
sick jacob see i don't even want doctor
doom
like i feel like doctor doom needs to be
like a presence throughout i don't want
him to just be
he's in fantastic four and then he beats
the fantastic four and then [ __ ] now
we're in secret wars like yeah i think
he needs to be an ongoing presence you
know what i mean i i think that is and
no i wasn't serious about making doctor
doom funny
i want him to be hilarious
nathan fielder's doctor
uh
will doom be the villain in thunderbolts
mr yanaz that's an interesting question
uh i don't think so daish is always
watching great videos she has go check
out her stuff thanks for being here dude
jacob pelletier i don't even know if
i've been pronouncing your name right
this whole time i say daisha oh i don't
know daishia what's the spelling
d-a-e-s-h-a
dasia asia
i feel like i get people i'm i'm i'm
notorious for getting people's names
wrong
hey gore was sober the entire movie of
viral
sake and sake uh
helen for doom
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my bad it's all good um
what are your most
anticipated projects announced
pull it back up yeah let's see
let's do
i gotta just go with my heart that might
be the most obvious answers um
blade and daredevil
although you know i'm i'm really
interested in ant-man and wasp
quantomania because you're you're you
take those two and i'll take that one
well i heard quantum mania the trailer
was really dark
and what i'm hoping for because
ant-man movies always get kind of the
short end of the stick
you're a punder i don't know
small end of the shrunken
okay so neither one of us right we were
wrong oh d-e-a okay yeah i wouldn't have
gotten it right so yeah i think that
when it comes to um when it comes to
ant-man quantum mania
i'm hoping that this one it seems like
this could be the biggest ant-man movie
and the most important integral one it's
like a lot of people felt like ant-man
and even though i really enjoyed ant-man
and the wasp people
it just came like right after infinity
war so it felt like there was i was like
what the [ __ ] is this that's a lot of
people
yeah and ant-man kind of went under the
radar a little bit and i feel like
quantum mania might be the first one
where people feel like this is really
vital and if it does have that dramatic
heft which would be such a such a swing
from the first two ant-man movies you
know because i feel like they'd have to
have some kind of balance where they do
have the comedy that you associate with
those ant-man films but also have the
drama and this is gonna be our first
time really because we saw he who
remains but this is the first time we're
going to see either the king or variant
of king either way it's going to be our
introduction to
kang king king king king king so i i'm i
am actually really but you know
the one i'm most interested is like
blade and durable like yeah there's the
ones that really wasn't it's funny you
texted us that poster beforehand and all
these things we've been hearing about
ant-man and it does have me really
excited and i do think that there's if
they can like i was hoping they would go
a bit darker for that movie and i hope
that maybe they can go to mixing in the
literal genre of dark comedy because i
feel like that could also temper the
mcu's i feel like even when they do
something serious the comedy is often
like light and whimsical and i feel like
that would be a cool opportunity to do
some legitimate dark comedy but um loki
season 2 is always going to be like high
up on my list and i'm really excited to
see the new captain america i really
want to see i'm always rooting for them
when they go to that extent and have
something that has to be sort of like a
geopolitical thriller um so i'm excited
to see anthony mackie take that on for
sure oh my god enter neon in the chat
might have just gave me a great t-shirt
idea let's do it kang gang and then you
got multiple
and then you put like a simpsons kang in
the background
it should be like the sopranos poster
yes yes yes that's what i do here i come
up with shirts
all we need now is a way to like
change the kang font so that you can put
a gun in it somewhere true true we'll
get don't worry demon one day we'll get
back to reacting some new rock stars
videos it's just been kind of a crazy
schedule and every video we do takes
time to prepare sometimes
depending on the video can take a few
hours so you know we actually might be
able to make the new rockstars ones
easier with with obs now oh sweet cool
we could do them like in picture uh so
yeah let's move on right here ready
green chile i love that i love when we
see people from other countries citizen
kang i had a shirt idea i told john
about yesterday it's verified this is my
way of copyrighting my
copywriting or someone you're a
copyrighted material
hey you're you're transforming it and
making it your own um
yeah but a citizen kang shirt i did i
told my john my whole idea yeah that's
coming keep a lookout on shop
zero edition.com
something influencer three no no we got
an actual url
nasaki
um
john and greg oh that's us there's eight
missing phase six movies will it be the
monster saga with midnight suns
moon night blade daredevil punisher will
be mutants before secret wars i think
it's absolutely going to be
um
mutants before secret wars i think if
you're going to do secret wars you're
going to kind of expect mutants and the
fact that miss marvel teased like
established she's a mutant you you need
you need mutants like at this point you
know quit [ __ ] us around marvel yeah
give us our [ __ ] music you owe us
this our [ __ ] man
yeah i feel like my my vibe i've gotten
is that phase six will definitely have
some more of like things that will
further set up whatever blade sets up
for midnight suns but yeah right you
gotta do uh mutants before like in a
more focal way in that phase also uh max
reviews thank you for the love on the uh
gravity falls reactions i think
i do think that phase seven through nine
that's when we're going to be very much
focused on the supernatural side of fans
that's when i because i you know that's
when i feel like phase seven will get
moon night season two yeah and by phase
seven they'll have worked out the issues
with china so that they'll eventually
show that's why they're waiting yeah
yeah
there's like little teases here and
there because yeah yeah right now it's
very multiverse timeline focused you
know you need to transition to things
yeah and i do think mutants would be the
the right first step and then that would
also
knowing characters from the mutant world
the expansion that brings you can get
more supernatural qualities from the
inclusion of certain mutants as well
yeah history nurses phoenix saga after
multiverse saga definitely that's what
we need is another phoenix saga josh
wren
huge win for daredevil
18 episodes is great just hope the
writing sorry please is as good as the
netflix seasons and that it's rated tvma
can't wait for this i do think it'll be
tvma because they they put the neff i
wanted to check it out on on disney plus
the when they moved over daredevil to
disney plus like did they censor
anything so i watched like the head
smash scene from season three you know
watch this the new show's gonna open
with uh him smashing two heads
two cards
and like this one take is the whole
episode
giant fights
yeah that that uh that was they still
maintained the the gore they didn't to
me when i was skimming it it didn't look
like they censored anything and i think
that is prepping us for no we will keep
it violent we will keep it r-rated it's
going to be tvma we're going to be like
oh look how edgy we are with our marvel
zombies and
maybe they'll be more edgy with that
show yeah like i'm so fascinated to see
what tvma means
to marvel actually you know gulam in the
chat is same units obviously introduced
in phase x
that would be cool if they waited until
phase 10 just so they could say phase x
phased yes you know what they should do
they should introduce wolverine in phase
10. yeah
weapon phase x that would be pretty
the
neat
is
saga how cool would that sound chris
wham off my boy
chris swamp is one of the nicest guys in
the world a moment of silence for chris
and uh it is so cool that we're just
getting more daredevil you know like you
can't get a there's so many times you
have fan petitions for things or fan
fans there's countless petitions for
[ __ ] and the fact that we that daredevil
was was true they're devil's like
like full-on resurrected yeah yeah yeah
so to call it daredevil born again i
don't know how much it's gonna adapt the
comic because season three already did
so much of that
but to call it born again is so apt for
the fan association of the demand of
wanting daredevil back yeah yeah and as
much as as much as a part of me goes
like oh i don't want them to like
overuse daredevil the other half of me
is like nah i'm so excited i'm so
excited to see charlie cox all over the
mcu
you just gotta have that i think the one
worries some people didn't alright
myself included wasn't a big fan of the
way kingpin was handled in hawkeye and
so i'm like don't don't do that [ __ ] do
that
i think they'll they'll improve on that
i think they will um yeah no i talked to
nerdcast asking the chat i talked to koi
a little bit yesterday and i'm like this
is the week we go gung-ho heal up get
better yeah right up jesus man uh hey
michael antonucci what an italian
anthony
hey john and greg that's us i know
you're not the biggest fan of volume two
guardians i'm assuming guardians of
galaxy vol 2. there's any second volume
of any story no i don't know albums you
name it yeah ivory every sophomore is a
slump but i really hope this next film
sticks the landing i actually really
love volume 2 but i know has issues and
i respect i respect your opinion
yeah i do think that volume two
um wasn't i'm not a big fan of volume
two personally but generally if we're
talking about james gunn love james gunn
movies like i think the suicide squad is
one of the best dc movies ever oh hands
i love the [ __ ] out of that movie um and
i love guardians one that's one of my
top 10 marvel films
and i really don't think james gunn's
gonna drop the ball in this one there's
so much riding i remember like you the
dude was fired then he came back with a
vengeance did a dc movie in between and
then a dc show between you yeah he's
he's coming back here his love for these
characters even though i'm not a big fan
of guardians 2 his love for those
characters still shines through that
movie yeah it's not an insult or or some
type of um
you know a mockery or turned him into a
joke or kind of the opinions that people
feel about taekwondo before 11th thunder
none of that registers with me even for
a film i didn't really like
and i think that with this one he knows
he keeps saying this is the ending he's
gonna make it the best it can possibly
be
and so i no matter what it turns out to
be like i feel like it'll read with a
feeling of
authenticity and true purpose behind it
so i do think it's going to be good and
it's really had the time
it's it's had so much time for love and
care and finesse to go into it that i
feel like yeah like i would be very
surprised if it wasn't something very
unique and special
you don't hear much about silver surfer
rom space knights pointing out george
don't it's
true kiana still would be like the
perfectly would be galactus is coming
what'd you guys think of the
pablo in the chats bringing up um uh
she-hulk uh the cox dynamic will be
great and yeah you know so excited i
think that she-hulk trailer
a lot of the times second trailers don't
seem to
the first trailer seems to leave always
leaves the biggest impression on
audiences that's constantly for people
who've like mainly covered trailers here
on this channel it seemed like that you
know first trailers always even if they
have a great second trailer a great
third trailer people's biggest takeaway
tends to be the first trailer and i
really do feel like for those who were
doubtful after the first trailer
it seems to have taken a major swing
towards you know what i'm actually
excited for this [ __ ] mm-hmm so i'm you
know dangerous phase five uh she-hulk i
mean
no yeah absolutely um speed one and
anything with daredevil will give you
automatic boost up the way to do it man
uh brayden thanks for being here uh
speed demon one one five two
now that daredevil is back with his own
series do you think we'll see the likes
of elektra eldon henson's foggy nelson
returning she brought so much of that
series and her fate remains unknown
i think you should bring them back they
were big parts of the of the show uh
especially you know those two like what
i would love is that d23 when they talk
about dear devil born again that they
announced the full lineup of the cast
and that they do say deborah and wolf
and and that guy who plays foggy
[Laughter]
yeah
that's that's one thing is yeah i really
hope they do bring back that cast
because i don't know
they've confirmed a lot of things like
oh the the captain carter isn't the same
captain carter's what if or whatever
else but i feel like bringing back the
charlie cox daredevil i feel like you
should bring back the rest like there's
so much that it seems like it would get
weird almost to try and recast all those
people plus then you could really get
people excited if they do decide to
bring back mike coulter and uh jessica
ritter and finn
wolfhard keanu reeves for ghost rider i
would prefer keanu reeves over a ghost
rider i mean counter is for a
ghostwriter more than i would prefer him
for silver surfer
i think he'd be [ __ ] perfect as
ghostwriter he'd just be so perfect it's
keanu reeves stuntman obsession with
motorcycles yeah yeah yeah
he's not i know he's not a stunt man but
he likes to do as much of his own stunts
norman reedus would also be a good pick
as jd's pointing out yeah that's good
anybody who's been on the amc show where
they ride the motorcycles could be ghost
writer uh brian pay pie pay should the
daniels direct the new avengers movies
that will go over well no no they
shouldn't i i would love it but daniel
uh everything everywhere
oh yeah yeah uh i i think that would be
cool that
would not go over well i would 100
be on board for that personally and i
would love to see how they juggle so
many things but i feel like they could
work in the mcu but they would need
something
more like
a guardians one type of thing where it's
like it's a whole swing it's something
different and crazy and you can kind of
go do your own thing and
and we'll go from there and it doesn't
have to be the nexus point of a thousand
other plans i feel like yeah
the more they can kind of do their weird
thing off to one side and i think the
more that we get obscure and more uh you
know broad characters brought into the
canon i think the more opportunities
you'll see for films like that well i
the way it seems like it works other
than joss whedon when it came to the
avengers movie
it seems like when they recording the
russo brothers or or the future the
prospect of directing future films it
seems like feige and company like to pay
attention to who will direct like what
are the
what are the reels looking like the
dailies and all that the edit has that
coming along for the movie that they're
working on and then they go oh maybe we
should have this person direct this
future movie you know john watts why
don't you direct fantastic four russo
brothers you're doing such a great job
as captain america ones what do you
think about the avengers films
b and and so i think that right now
they're kind of seeing which director
they have yeah that's like do it that's
what's exciting is that you see who does
particularly well at what thing in each
of these current two next phases and
then that will sort of bring to the top
whoever is the best choice exactly yeah
exactly which i think is is kind of
smart the way they do that
this somebody said that ryan gosling
keanu reeves and uh charlie hunnam and
norman rita should all play different
ghost riders you know after seeing ryan
gosling in [ __ ] um engraving actually
ryan gosling would be a good silver
surfer i i can see that yeah oh do it oh
please do it thank you ginger that's a
really sweet sweet thing to say hulk did
break the fourth wall that's right
actually ryan coogler might not be a bad
pick for the avengers films i was
wondering about that that's a good fit
especially after seeing i think that
black panther triggers so good because
it's so cinematic you know whatever it
is qualms people have
with like all marvel movies look and
feel the same or whatever [ __ ]
people say right
that trailer to me and like come on
that's a cinematic ass trailer that is a
hundred year old yeah oh yeah yeah that
is that is like epic trailer [ __ ] yeah
that's exciting like
like it just seems so moving um robert
soriano
looking forward to wakana forever and if
victor doom is getting introduced if yes
then i want doom and king to have 1v1
what if secret wars was just that just
them duking it out them versing each
other yeah
on some they're they're just on vormir
fighting yeah i love it
um thank you robert heroes reforged
thank you adam
um alexander greenert thank you for
being here adam if that's if if you're
if you're in the chat let us know
he's the only one who knows us and likes
us between the three of the people that
heroes report you know
hector's looked at me in the past uh but
uh i feel like adam how how often do
people actually get your name right yeah
comment below
uh and thank you we're happy to be
feeling better and thank you for your
advice adam gave us some good tech
advice
ooh you know jensen ackles in the chat
someone's asking jensen jensen echoes in
the chat as uh jensen apples as cyclops
i feel like they need they need to go
younger i mean jensen
has a great youthful quality about it he
does but i feel i think they they need
to go younger
yeah that's the way to do it
yeah ben wolfhard as cyclops
but i agree i think i have optic blast
coming in my eyes this is always whining
yeah yeah yeah i just blow everything up
and i don't want it no get get uh no
schnapp get his bowl cut with that vice
oh yeah yeah it was just cast all the
strangers all the stranger things in
there
oh dead shot in the chat uh dead shot
think we'll get mature content like
marvel zombies and deadpool 3 like blade
and thunderbolts could be rated r i feel
like they're gonna um depending on
budget
that's how they're gonna
they're gonna they're gonna register
everything
i think blade's gonna be pg-13 i don't
think it's gonna be rated r which is a
bummer to think about it is but i feel
like there's a scenario depending on who
and how you handle it where they could
at least
teeter on the edge of rated r
i don't know i feel like that'll be that
worried about i feel like i really feel
like it needs to be rated r yeah
i'm curious because part of me goes well
the original blade movies were mostly
rated r so maybe this would be an
opportunity to try something quote new
and go pg-13 but no you know like we not
that that will be morbias but you know
like morby has had a bunch of scenes
where it's like here's vampire action
with no
the most important substance to a
vampire movie blood
and so yeah i i feel like it would be
fascinating to watch them do an r-rated
blade i think that's more likely than an
r-rated thunderbolts i feel like they
need thunderbolts if that's going to end
the phase to be as broadly appealing as
possible yeah um so yeah
they completely forgot the phil colson
solo trilogy i need it all right
mister
agents of shield fan yeah i just
finished it come on over to patreon and
watch with me is very emotional
i've talked so much about fantastic four
in the past john who will be your
fantastic fourth
okay um you guys in the chat who would
your fantastic forecast be i want gerard
carmichael as reid richards i want
regina hall as sue storm i want
um i want terry crews's thing and i want
um
will smith as uh
johnny storm
i don't mind those pics that's my mix
the ages are all screwed up
but uh somehow if you get will smith in
there
you know and he
johnny storm will be the lead yeah
yeah the way it has to go william
that's what we always wanted i i i would
cast for real
reid richards not a bad pick i would
like a dev patel oh my god i'm gonna
steal that that's a good one patel
wouldn't be a bad pick that is a great
choice
danny devito was wolverine that would be
an awesome thing too
i want it actually actually you know the
rumors about penn badgley coming around
as reed richards and i do think you
would be a good pick i could see that
i i yeah from from the vague things i
know him from i could see that the the
uh
the guy from top gun the maverick the
[ __ ] pilot glenn yeah yeah glenn
something howl glenn powell yeah you go
um
a lot of people are are saying that he
might be cyclops
oh or he could be cyclops or he could be
human torch
i was going to say make him bend grip
um
yeah i could see that i could see him as
either of those i could probably see him
more as as human torch just because of
the attitude from top gun sure but uh i
mean i would certainly watch him as
cyclops
um i'm so s yeah will ferrell is like
close exactly mom in the chat just keep
keep going yeah zac
for that uh little feral thing
the guy who played mini me as colossus
joe curious human torch is not a bad bad
yeah and my thoughts on neymar i love
the look of namor so much he seems he
seems scary but i think the makeup on
everything we're seeing the atlanteans
and and neymar especially it looks so
phenomenal get joseph quinn to be human
torch everyone loves eddie munson i
think that's one thing that we don't we
didn't really touch on enough especially
with the first black panther movie in
this one is that the the makeup really
is you know sometimes you get so caught
up in cgi they don't take time to
appreciate the practical and i think the
practical here looks great because a lot
of times the practical is more
associated with like the gritty street
level [ __ ] but when you got something
that's like massive as black panther
wakanda forever
you gotta appreciate the costume design
and the makeup and everything four
squeezy
roland john deleonte did you think that
phase five will have a world war hulk or
ghost rider movie
ghost rider more likely but i honestly
don't expect either
i'm really leaning more towards a world
war hulk movie actually we know that
phase five will not have either of those
movies space five has been announced but
phase six basics yeah yeah yeah i was on
the same page
yeah yeah i it's
i feel like world war hulk is like once
like the multiverse is like a big thing
that we're dealing with and it could
certainly open the doors for that but i
feel like that's something you would see
right we get even further into like the
the more they the deeper they get the
more these movies really start to feel
like the craziness of like the actual
comic book universe but i feel like
they're not quite far long enough for uh
world war hulk in that respect uh ghost
rider yeah i could certainly see sooner
or at least appearing yes in a
significant way in phase five or six oh
emb in the chat actually pitched evan
rachel wood as susan storm and i i'm
only on season three of westworld right
now been catching up on it because paul
heavy spoilers was uh he's been covering
it and he made me go you know what i
want to catch up on on westworld and uh
i think evan rachel would could possibly
pull it off actually and then aaron paul
could be the human
he could be her balls it could be human
torture yeah i would love that
john say a human torch line
aaron paul voice do it
picture i'm just going to take the
trailer
picture this but everywhere [ __ ]
you did it mr white
uh and somebody said sasha baron cohen
for uh for doctor doom did you do they
say i could see that that'd be cool i
would like that everyone a lot of people
yeah
it would be so upsetting when people
find that out i really think that dr
doom if marvel could get their leaks
under control
i think it would be so awesome if we
like daniel rpk doesn't find it like
like my time to shine hello doesn't like
if no one finds out about who doctor
doom is and then we don't see it till
the freaking post-credits scene or
whenever he appears would be incredible
i really really
am hoping we do not learn who's playing
dr doom until marvel wants us to see
who's playing doc that would be so
gratifying i've seen a lot of people in
the chat today mention anthony anthony
star as dracula i know that's a big wish
right uh is there is there any is that
like an actual rumor i've seen it so
many times in this gym an actual actual
rumor
do you think that would work
um given where he would be coming over
from
yeah i mean
sometimes marvel does like to play
against type
i guess and that wouldn't be against
type so that's why i'm like i'm not sure
about that i just feel like it would be
weird to see him go from the boys
then go to marvel yeah
yeah that's a good point because the
boys is like like anti-wrestling
yeah yeah that's true that's a good
point so then to see him
it would be like distracting in a way
almost yeah that's a really good point
maurice mccrath thank you blame on [ __ ]
flame on mr
mr richards
uh
actually tyler hulkland who play hecklin
who plays uh superman in the
superman alois show would actually be a
good doctor doom if someone says i would
like that is there a way to put the chat
on like slow-mo because there's so many
coming in and we're like hopping back
and forth between the actual chat and
then the super chats which we appreciate
guys thank you so much yeah let's see
see if we can slow down the uh
slow it down even more
is it on slo it's on slow mode right now
it's on uh
it's it's slow-ish okay i said it's like
a 25 second delay or something yeah we
need a little bit more of a delay so we
can keep up with what everyone's saying
okay
but can you also like have it be visible
so i can read what people are saying
while you're figuring out the hard
technical parts
[Music]
amazon is not going to give aunt so wait
hold on a sec sorry if i'm confused by a
check and someone help me about what
sarah williamson we're always here what
is confusing here
foss bender as doom is like i think foss
runner can do [ __ ] anything but i
don't i don't want him with doom viggo
mortensen as doom i think would be a
great choice although i don't see viggo
mortensen wanting to commit to
franchises again it seemed really burnt
out after the whole um experience of
of uh you know
that one franchise i lowered the race
yeah giancarlo esposito
i i don't want to play any more villains
i'm on the i'm i'm i think the i'm
caught up to date with a better call
saul i think he's an amazing villain
actor
far cry mandalorian better call saw
breaking bad same character i know but
more exploration and better call saul
he's played countless villains even in
westworld season two he played like a
menacing character in this one-off role
i don't know if his character comes back
or not but uh i thought he was great but
i don't want to see giancarlo esposito
play doctor doom even though he would be
great casting i'm just sick of seeing
him play villains um i think giancarlo
esposito would be a great professor x
though i would like i would really enjoy
him as professor x he'd be a great pick
i would love that because he because
even when he's being evil he has that
thing where if you don't understand
what's lurking
yeah he has this like warm comforting
quality to it yeah yeah it's like a
vuncular thing so i would love to see
him as a professor i think he could i
think he'd be a great great and luke
neeson is doctor doom not a bad guy
i like it kevin feige
nikolai koster waldo is doom uh jamie
lannister it'd be interesting actually
uh john can i see this for a sec no all
right you keep reading the chats while
i'm loading a different page right heck
yeah
uh
i would read the chat i'm sorry i'm
probably blocking it
it's all good
uh oh yeah we should jump over here yeah
yeah we will all right yeah we got a
bunch of super chats and stuff that we
want to get to so thank you guys i mean
you see there's some in stream labs that
we haven't gone into yet so we'll
definitely do that yeah nikolai
costervaldo would be interesting there
there are a lot of interesting ah the
problem is there's so many good ones i
would love to see killian murphy in the
mcu i don't know if he'd be interested
carrie anderson saying jessica chastain
is sue storm i would love that just to
piss off grace randolph that'd be so
funny
and then do nothing beats a grace
randolph random and then do a multiverse
oh goodness but do a multiverse thing
where you have jessica chastain play sue
storm and then and then bryce dallas
howard shows up as super storm and then
you know have reid get confused as to
which ones which actually melissa
benning us to susan storm is not about
she looks like she could be the
character she's got that
traditional white blonde girl look at
that who's great for a lot of comic book
characters that exist bill hater reed
richards let's do it bye all right so
johnny can you pull this up
over here yep
all right oh you have a tab there that's
all good this is this this is perfect
this is uh
this is up to date
there we go right here
javier bardem see that's another one
hobby bar damn i think it would be a
great pick as doom although you don't
freaking michael shannon who is a
predictable villain would be a great
doctor dammit it's so hard to pick
there's so many good people who can play
doctor doom there's so many good people
who can play dr doom
let's see here uh we got here in the
stream labs which we really appreciate
you know thank you we want to make sure
we don't end the stream without getting
everyone who contributed so thank you
uh but frankie j
that was the right one i loaded us
proper john
there you go that's what i'm trying to
do stop moving what does he say john
reed does the avengers secret wars ends
on a good note i feel like this will
lead to something crazy big and kind of
want it to end on something like
infinity war
i mean given what the comic cool i love
that
i mean i feel like you could do
something interesting where
you end on a note where
it's not the same like oh my god like we
lost and this is a heavy dark day like
if infinity war has that kind of ending
where you're like oh man the toll and
and we really lost i feel like secret
wars could end in such a way where
you at least if they're going anywhere
near the comic you got the formation of
battle world and all that stuff and that
that saves us from the massive incursion
of the multiverse and the things all
breaking apart but that's also a very
sinister portent moving ahead so like
you could have some kind of bittersweet
rap to that where it's like oh you know
like
you know what i'm trying to get out
where it's like we think we're saved but
oh no this is just the sign of a bigger
nastier thing to come well
you know i i really love the tone of
avengers end game when it is dark and
dower and what i liked about falcon and
winter soldier series i don't think it's
brought up enough is seeing the the dark
world after gloom effects that were had
like like you know
sam wilson trying to get a [ __ ] loan
from the bank you know yeah yeah and and
seeing like the the effects of the world
and i think if secret wars ended on a
dark note
that would be really cool to see this
sort of looming darkness for a few films
moving forward you know what i mean like
inhabiting that world
like borderline apocalyptic world
feeling you know what i mean and to see
the mcu embody that as opposed to like
all right we're back it's all good
setting up a new threat let's go you
know yeah i think having something that
just resonates over the the film
properties as we're in a different
landscape now when we step back into
this world how it like yes switch up
your genres and all that and introduce
more characters whatever
but having a world that does feel
generally like there's some there's a
darkness over like looming over it the
entire time
would be
more appealing and then again like i'm
saying i'm opting that phase seven
through nine is gonna be your
supernatural phases and then if you are
having your dark supernatural [ __ ] like
midnight suns and all that and moon
night season two
i think would be [ __ ] incredible like
that would be amazing i think that makes
sense too because yeah you have the
early phases you have you know the the
the origins of everything and then you
have the the moments of intense darkness
at the end of the infinity saga giving
way to the intense color and you know
variety of the multiverse and then yeah
to go from all that you know
brightness and that variation to then
something that is decidedly more heavy
and more sinister moving forward i think
would be a cool choice mr sinister
daniel craig has doomed see i don't
think that's going to happen either i
feel like there's a lot of actors who
are burnt out on franchises someone has
asked if they should cast a romani actor
given doom's heritage i think that would
be cool if they cast somebody who we're
not all thinking about i gave a lot of
wrong theories leading up to saturn
that was way off on
most things peter capaldi
flat out said they're not going to say
anything about avengers but we're going
to hear something about mutants and i
was like oh that was the exact opposite
of what happened
i just want all the doctor who's to play
dr doom i want peter capaldi and matt
smith and uh david actually capaldi as
doom would be cool that would be cool
right paul diaz doom would be great i
would love that i mean you know he'd
have to work out that accent but uh but
yeah i would so love that i wanted to do
some the panda's saying grant gustin is
mr fantastic i wanted to do a shirt but
i don't really want to cap capitalize on
ezra miller uh but i wanted to assure
they had a photo of grant gustin and it
says better than ezra
[Laughter]
good that's it because there's a man not
better than ezra
and some better than ezra fan who's
gonna be like this is
who remembers who better than ezra
nobody references this
a dolphin hit her
oh that's a dolphin hitler
i think they're both you're great right
do you think black panther wakanda
forever will be his story as
historically powerful as the first
very much so uh like focusing on strong
strong good representation for women in
the movies this time as the society uh
critic i f i mean i feel like all that
stuff is going to be a part of it uh you
know because you have so many focal and
powerful female characters throughout
the the whole you know sort of structure
of wakanda so i feel like that just
comes with the territory yeah um but i
think it will definitely be a cult it's
gonna be a cultural moment no matter
what because of the real life
circumstances the collision of
the i saw a tweet that ryan airy posted
and we've all kind of talked it but i
think he had a really concise way of
putting it which was you know the
characters on or maybe you said this to
me i don't know the characters on screen
are mourning
the actors on screen are mourning for
the same person as the character that
everyone's mourning for and and the
audience is all mourning for so it's
like this rare merging of real life and
art and i feel like that in and of
itself is going to make it a cultural
moment plus
in black panther movie i feel like ryan
coogler part of what he would i don't
think he would want to make a black
panther movie that doesn't have some
level of commentary on the world and you
know the sort of geopolitical state of
things and you know the cultural state
of things and i think yeah on both
levels as an emotional cultural event it
will be definitely that but also i'm
sure it will have thoughts on its mind
yeah and it's
it has to
be like plain and simple it has to be
there's no way it wouldn't uh and i i
wonder if it will have some type of
environmentalist quality too yeah i bet
it would you know something that i think
you know neymar
a lot of a lot of people easily easily
summarize namor as that's marvel's
aquaman character and you know in the
first aquaman movie they had like lines
that through
environmental commentary they're just
kind of like tossed in there and didn't
really have that much of it of an affect
even though it was like that is the
point of patrick wilson like a [ __ ] the
humans uh but it didn't really like go
into the commentary and and i don't know
how much it'll dive into this but i feel
like
because of the position that they've
been thrusted into i don't want to sit
here and go this will be better than the
first black panther movie but i feel
like it's going to be very different and
i think it's going to be extremely
character and personal based because
the position that ryan coogler was put
in
naturally warrants like you need to keep
it personal you need to
so because this is going to have to be a
cathartic release for a lot of people
you know
there will be fallout from wakanda being
open to the world they just have to
address that at some point but yeah it
will be more emotional personal like i
think that uh you know my one of my the
one
my favorite experience from black
panther uh was the second time i watched
it
and it it's something that i'm not gonna
cry on the stream
you got this not gonna happen
always gets me uh
uh okay here we go i'm gonna do i'm
gonna be fine
i'm gonna get through this because we
got a lot to get through
but it was when um we saw black panther
and they stick around for post credits
and whatever and and and then
when the theater was was emptying out
you know i saw this black family that
was theirs little little kid a little
kid and then a mom and they stood in
front of the the theater screen
and then you know did the wolf wakanda
forever pose and took a photo
and to me that was just so touching
because i'm like oh this is you know
it's not like a big group of people but
just seeing this family that waited for
the theater to clear out just so they
could have this memory of seeing this
movie that's so much more important to
to them than it would be for myself
something were so impossible
yeah yeah yeah and and i and to me
that's that's always that's been my
number one association is that one
memory of just seeing that family wait
behind for everyone to leave so they
could have this personal moment to take
a photo to say that we like to remember
this moment of a movie i'm like that's
that's that's who this movie is for
that's what i that's what i think about
when people complain about
representation and stuff is i'm like
sometimes not everybody does it in a way
that isn't clunky but like that's what
it's for is is like imagine that joy
like like if you've experienced that you
know other people should too john gonna
need your help here big time never spent
a long time i know it's been a long time
black panther answered
michael mack donated thanks michael mack
thank you really appreciate that
donating here because i think it
supports you guys more it does it does
better yeah man that black panther
trailer was beautiful first trailer to
make me shed tears guardians of the
galaxy three probably gonna cause tears
to lol heard daniella melchior has been
cast in an undisclosed two rat catcher
two uh love oh really scotland that's
who she is
uh yeah yeah i believe so yeah there's
so there's certain directors like that
james gunn it's like you want to just
get in that crap you're the troop you
want to get into that true like
christopher nolan he has the same actors
like i know that when i get that call
i'm like oh cool role i was reading an
interview with uh josh hartnett who was
saying how he was asked to play batman
and batman begins yes and then he he
turned it down damn it because of
whatever obviously turn it down he
turned it down and he said he regrets it
primarily because he wish he could be in
with the christopher nolan group of
actors and keep working experience
and james gunn has that same thing you
know like i was expecting more people
from the suicide squad to actually be in
this movie you know like has they ha has
uh
das mulchy and david dust monster and
been in any of the guardians films has
he played do you guys know who david hey
do you know who remember who david he
played polka dot man but do you know if
david does mulch has been in any of the
guardians movies because i feel like
he'd be a perfect addition to the
guardians films yeah he would he would
be a perfect character i feel like maybe
he's shown up as like a cameo or some
kind of one-off but yeah like to give it
an actual character please do oh chilean
murphy as doctor doom would be a great
pick too
i actually really like that a lot yeah i
definitely would oh david those
mulchings and ant-man that's right yeah
thank you david yeah yeah yeah david
mess
i feel so stupid for forgetting that now
because he got such a boosted role in
the second movie and i remember being
excited for that i appreciate yeah he
could play something he could be an
alien freaking [ __ ] yeah give me an
alien chance two characters yeah
michelle yo
is one character she there's just two
characters she's ravagers and she's in
shanghai yeah
yeah yeah
it's possible yeah it's [ __ ]
happening
it could happen
don't take our dreams scrumptious
badonkadonk thank you
for twerking it into the chat here
guys really quick mads mickelson is
doctor doom please he's the one
exception where i'm like i only want to
see him play
i don't know
you don't you don't want to see that
movie where he plays a guy just trying
to get sober i've seen him in interviews
and i really enjoy his interviews and
and i think
you can only see him play villains for
everyone else i'm like nah i'm sick of
playing
yeah he could definitely do it someone
said brian but he was already uh because
cecilia's caicilius yeah let's see uh
brian cranston doctor doom call i think
that could be fun
i am the one who knocks uh scrumptious
badonkadonk hey guys i'm so excited for
the upcoming movies and shows especially
after the coven stuff some good [ __ ]
i am excited too too especially after
the coven stuff yes it seems kevin
[ __ ] came out on stage and said cobit
is done marvel's done marvel destroyed
covenant
back to l.a where numbers are higher
than ever everyone take off your mask in
this auditorium
take off your basket stomp on it and
stomp on your neighbor's mask we're not
doing this anymore uh yeah it's it seems
nice to get to a point where you can
tell like okay now kovit is not wrecking
their plans and destroying their
schedules and that alone is nice um okay
carl urban is wolverine a bit
predictable but also a hundred percent
perfect i'd be completely down for that
a million years and and the scourge had
a shaved head so people won't realize
um meryl streep is doctor do you imagine
they cast a woman to be doctor knew how
well that would go over with them
the internet
foster to you um shouldn't gummy i just
read your comment thank you uh flev
doran fled my man flev one of our top
super citizen reject people coming up
different names for that king defeated
covet he went through the timeline
christine oh my god kevin hart is gonna
be in a [ __ ] like black adam movie
there's something that's oh yeah you
know dwayne johnson's gonna court him
for that so that's why
um phleb door and hi guys like we don't
read the chat i'm like what the [ __ ] is
people you don't pay attention to the
stream we're clearly reading jethro i
wouldn't hate daniel radcliffe as
wolverine either devon hamilton hey flev
hi guys i'm at work now so i might get
fired i might not catch you live as for
the news i'm hyped daredevil finally
gets the recognition he deserves and
event and two avengers films six months
apart i think that still breaks
records yeah definitely the best sequels
released in the same year
you know it's a curious thing that
they've decided to do that but i'm
actually pretty excited like i i
appreciated the end game and the
infinity war in that order being spaced
a year apart but i feel like having to
the two back to back as much of an
eyebrow raise as that has been for some
people i think that could be a neat
choice can you pull up the phase six
slate again i i don't remember if
there's something in between
there is there is two slots there are
two slots in between so the way how
there was captain marvel and ant-man
there is there are two slots yeah
can't put it on screen yeah
what the hell john we should have
buttons ready to go i know
hold on you know we did all this work
staying home at comic-con and then soups
just killed it 1.5 million views
just recording people at comic-con
let's go
it's just just one video
take it easy on soups okay
he didn't get his cavalry henry cavill
wasn't there
you didn't hear the sound of hall h
being like stomped to the ground
the stage
okay off henry cavill's lit so so there
will what from what i can gather from
this it will be two series
i think when they write summer or or a
time of year instead that means it's a
series um so i feel like there will be
really yeah because the movie is someone
point that out to you or did you just
kind of like put that together that's my
speculation i mean this phase is a lot
more vague so i could be wrong but like
looking at the phase five uh you know
like the movies seem to have a date
release interesting theory i like that
uh yeah cause yeah it seems like the
movies have a release date and then the
shows have a window of time or a season
of the year that they'll be in um so
yeah it looks like there will be two
shows but these could be two movies
maybe they just don't have dates locked
or something like that because there is
a big space between these two um
all right oh [ __ ] yeah we'll see
one two three four six i i think
sometimes when you take like 11
properties though
it's safe to presume that kang dynasty
will end in a way that's also setting up
for something to be completed as a part
two of sorts for
avengers secret wars right yeah and i
think the the one feeling i hope that
audiences are left with are what
happened with ant-man and the wasp you
know feeling like the in-between
projects don't feel
completely necessary or feel a little
inconsequential into the overall bigger
picture because you know nothing gets
bigger than a than a [ __ ] avengers
movie you know yeah nothing gets bigger
than that so i hope they don't just like
throw something to the wind
in there and then like let's give a an
ending or a post-credits scene that that
shows this is this was an important film
you know yeah so let's contextualize
this in hindsight um yeah if you look at
this you have uh dates for movies and uh
windows for shows um but yeah
fascinating back to the stream labs can
you pull the chat back up too definitely
a lot of windows here yes
ooh jamie campbell bauer no more
pointless shows doctor doom jamie
campbell bower could be cool could be
cool
all righty moving on up
see there is a project slated before
fantastic four as demons pointing out so
i don't know i don't know i just think
it'd be a great thing i think we're
gonna get two villains
we're gonna have kang as the front and
center but oh my god there was a there
was another there was someone
i think when we get doctor doom is going
to be insane it is going to be i love
how all the talk of my fist gave him
more points mephisto and i was just
thinking about this last night no one's
talking about mephisto anymore it really
that's phase seven through nine
supernatural phase that's what i'm
holding just when everyone i'm holding
on to that i'm holding on to that
adam p farnsworth i hope to see william
jackson harper uh chidi from the good
place as mr fantastic i'm actually not
familiar with that person's work but i
appreciate you putting that out there
and i hope that comes true for yourself
i do like william jackson harper i don't
know if i could see him quite as doom
but i like i like where your head's at
where's your head go back up those and
then uh look greg saying looking hot
today guys i appreciate this oh you're
looking hot greg any greg's in the chat
are all automatically looking up g thin
do you think any of the marvel any of
the shows of marvel is pointless
no doesn't seem like
seems like there's a point to them all
that they all eventually will set up
oh something i want to know what
people's uh definition of pointlessness
is in this context because like bryce
welcome to your first real rejects live
the only reason interrupts are oh no
absolutely welcome uh yeah what is your
uh uh criteria for disappointment is it
about seeing all of these is
is it about seeing the interconnectivity
in a very direct and upfront kind of way
because i feel like some of these things
are still allowed to exist in a more
isolated fashion and i think it's good
for the mcu to have things that are all
involved in some way but certain things
are much more involved than others
because that gives you time to a
add variety and b have things that can
become way more grave and important
later too
um so i don't know i haven't felt like
it's not connected phantom 26 saying i
am group might be pointless in my
opinion and that is probably the only
one that might not be entirely essential
viewing yeah i mean that seems like a
light fluffy fun that seems like the
point is to have some fun
um let's see here let's go back michael
antonucci so i think what if i hope what
if becomes necessary at least with the
watu uh the watcher i hope that become
that's when it becomes necessary yeah i
would it would be very gratifying to
have them because i remember on their
promise i remember the people breaking
down the thor love and thunder easter
eggs just from the trailer alone and you
see the watcher in the background and
you got the freaking celestials there
and and you know you got all these
different statues of people
i remember just being like that's
probably that's probably all it is
just references
easter eggs
ben foster's mephisto says jt i like
that choice
michael and hanuch
do you think deadpool 3 will be released
in 2025 because not all phase six titles
were revealed
yes
i mean deadpool 3 is something i
full-heartedly believe i thought they
would mention it at this because of the
fact that like
they've got the writers already speaking
about yeah we're writing it right now
we're working on it and then you know
you you have kevin feige say yeah it's
gonna be rated r we're gonna be making
it it's so obviously being worked on
right now
and you know they haven't confirmed at
least to my knowledge they haven't
confirmed who the director is there's
many talks about sean levy uh being the
director and i feel like that's probably
the case
but i wholeheartedly believe that d23
they will say deadpool three and then
here's who's gonna be in it
which would be cool if they brought
cable back then you'd have josh brolin
asked us
you could really double down on some
jokes there it's a real multiverse i
just hope they let i really hope they
let deadpool go hog wild and really take
the piss out of the mcu like if they can
make
jokes like
i don't know some people thought phase
four was kind of pointless
like saying [ __ ] like that would be
awesome get ready mcu and no one's safe
yes i would love it
blink that's going to be the real test
of how much balls do most people have is
that that's the thing is i really will
be the ultimate i really hope they're
willing to to really rib themselves i
feel like that's the way to win with
deadpool is to really go
to
roast us blink
loving thank you blink all marvel's news
where's our house of the dragon reaction
hbo max gives this way too many problems
there's so many headaches but we're we
are considering actually just reacting
to the actual show
and be an interesting experience
for not having done the trailers it
would be just watch the show what's up
going cold seeing what matt smith's up
to yeah be like oh [ __ ] i don't remember
what happened in game of thrones and all
these game of thrones fans are yelling
at me damn no i tried i forgot that i
forgot massive
that one part oh i forgot that one
we refer to the wall i've constructed of
names houses timelines and connections
between them all that they're they're
right why watch this if i'm not a loyal
reader of every moment of i don't know
world history enough and now i got to
learn this fake world history but thank
you blink uh yeah we're
more than likely covering it more likely
the crypto boy hey why haven't marvel
contact you guys to make a small cameo
the soups has taken the cameos yeah
maybe maybe avengers con scene or
something like that well the crypto boy
as much of an honor as it is is not
something i'm ever expecting to happen
in our lives they'll have us on screen
hosting a panel
that would be cool though that would be
cool we wouldn't say no
the beloved savage i'd want to be badass
enough to say no then we could do a
video about how i told them i turned
down more boys to call it i am not a
marvel [ __ ] yeah and here's why
the beloved savage lol i want to quit my
job and work for marvel
i hope you can one day yeah
jon hamm would be a perfect doctor to
keep these doctor doom castings coming
jon hamm would be a perfect doctor doom
i think jon hamm would be a wonderful
addition to the mc he would be i would
love it chris rock is galactus let's do
it
beta ray bill but it's just bill murray
no makeup
oh yeah there's just bill murray should
be all over the emcee did we ever learn
what happened with that that thing he
got fired from was he fired from it i
forget the thing that halted i know it
halted production
but i heard what he was replaced out of
some wes anderson movie now
yes he's not gonna be in in yeah his
upcoming movie but i'm not 100 sure what
the circumstances are as of now i
thought it was a scheduling thing but
they say that to cover up all sorts of
other things what i'm surprised about in
this chat is no one's talking about
craving the hunter
uh-huh everyone knows craven the hunter
is gonna blow
blow the doors open the power structure
in the sony pictures universe of marvel
characters is about to change
this is something i did not talk about
um
this is something i haven't talked about
but i remembered
i remember
um
reading on my phone
uh with olivia i remember reading on my
phone
craven the hunter is an animal lover
what and i just started like cracking up
so hard because i was like they're gonna
[ __ ] this movie up so fast yeah and then
i saw the stills of him running and i'm
like ah he's just gonna be like some
generic probably american dude running
through with it
and just gonna watch it again just gonna
watch it
i just started laughing so much when i
when i read that it's called craven the
hunter
and uh and he wears like pelts in so
many depictions so funny
so funny i mean
it still makes me laugh to this day
it's just like come on guys let's learn
no they gotta believe the kids they
gotta update them they gotta use us
they're using what the kids love they
love irony and they love rights of all
varieties be they civil social animal
so that's that's what the kids need and
then madame webb
it's gonna be great you know female lead
up those people love it i feel like
they're trying to lean into the there
were the b movies
i like that i if they can commit to that
then [ __ ] it honestly but it doesn't it
looks like they're they're caught in
between not knowing which way to lean
honestly i'm with coy on that and i feel
like and and and you as well i and yeah
i feel like
i feel like because they want to be the
enemy
so much
yes
it's a pleather jacket
yeah craven just goes around dumping
buckets of red paint on people and nice
coats
uh but yeah if sony if they would let go
a little bit of their whole like we're
the mcu too kind of thing and just
embraced being the bee movie side and
have a lot of fun with that i feel like
that could be awesome as heck and uh
yeah there are swirling rumors about
bill murray whether it was just he uh
dropped out because of the rona or if
there's worse uh things
ahead something about a difference of
opinion with wes anderson so we'll see
it's weird are they we're so much
together i know maybe they're not
friends anymore
bill murray always falling out with his
directors
um
oh i didn't know olivia wilde someone
doing mata webb i completely missed that
information olivia wilde do it man what
oh that sounds familiar to me now she
and florence you are apparently feuding
really why there there's been a a
controversy of sorts because florence
pugh posts a lot about the movies she's
in on her social media and has posted
nothing
about don't worry darling and there are
rumors that uh she had to direct lots of
that movie because olivia wilde became
very involved with harry styles
and some sort of conflicting triangle
really risen and so yeah she has and
people were saying there was a new
trailer for don't worry darling and the
poster for oppenheimer dropped and she
put up the oppenheimer poster but did
not share anything about don't worry
darling and so people assume there's
some kind of trouble afoot you know what
i've heard is that ryan gosling and
chris evans are feuding really
and and
it did make me it did make me go oh wait
like the second i heard that i went
they don't do they barely
ryan gosling nice guys a lot of russell
crowe and ryan gosling blade runner a
lot of ryan gosling and harrison ford
yes emma stone a lot of ryan glass
there's none of the you'd think they
would be doing a bunch of interviews
where it's just ryan gosling and chris
evans capturing their chemistry together
and i'm like you don't really see them
together
and that's like the bummer of the movie
and yeah i wonder if they're vindy's on
the rock now
i can't imagine what they would have to
feud over
i have no idea either yeah yeah he's
doing spider woman not madame webb okay
okay but some i mean there's there's
other speculations that like madame webb
isn't actually what they're doing with
that and they're doing some kind of like
like there will be madame webb but it's
also going to introduce spider-man and
other things
uh it's going to have a team of ladies
yeah we're not going to watch those
league trailers but what we will do
is wait for them to come out and give
you a great reaction then
um
todd andrew bp2 trailer wow we all
witnessed something amazing we did
full-heartedly agree
absolutely beautiful thank you for that
mikey watson uh thank you mikey do you
think we'll see some old heroes from
past movies hulk 2003 or hugh jackman et
cetera and secret wars if they can pull
that [ __ ] off for just some like crazy
cameo experience that would be
absolutely beautiful especially if it is
some type of like triumphant moment or
some [ __ ] like that
but if we could do that that would be
amazing that would be incredible i i
really really would love to see
them brought back for anything and they
de-age everyone now even at times it
doesn't seem that necessary they danger
so yeah like do what you got to do but
you know just just just to honor that
the eric bannon you know it'll be a real
baller move if they got back
the fantastic four movie that's that one
that was not released that was just made
so they could hold on to the rights uh
i've never seen it you know the original
fantastic four the actual like yeah the
roger corbin fantastic four movies yeah
if they brought them in at some point
that would be the most awesome movie
that would be really where you would be
like i have no idea who the [ __ ] these
people are most people have no idea who
they are but it would be the ultimate
easter egg i would love it somebody
somebody in the chat said matthew modine
dr brenner as uh professor x do you
think that would work
hello eric
definitely tom dillon mcavoy mckevin
i've always thought you were alone logan
but you're not and then they put him in
a pizza's freezer
do you see midnight suns fitting into
things as a movie event or tv show going
forward also when are you lovely fellas
come into the uk london for the win
uh
midnight sun i would want midnight suns
to be a movie if you had like that be
your sort of like hell avengers that
could be really cool that would be
awesome yeah you're doing like offshoot
avengers you know you got thunderbolts
um
you have young avengers you have young
avengers and
you have you got midnight
yeah i mean you got the guardians of the
galaxy which will then have a new group
but if you have midnight suns as a movie
i feel like you can go a little bit more
r-rated yeah be
it would be cool
i mean like the defenders on netflix
while i know that wasn't like fully mcu
yet
um
that was a letdown i want them to do
another if if they bring back all the
netflix people i feel like they should
give the defenders a movie like a real
shot at doing something special that'd
be cool that's that's one thing i think
should be redone
and i would hope msr that gabriel luna
would get a shot at uh coming back as
ghost writer too nobody wants that john
i agree i was i don't know what i was
thinking samara samir semede uh dad
hey son what happened to comic-con son
basically [ __ ] you pulled out his thing
and yelled at him
[Laughter]
his best super
yeah if more if more super chats could
be delivered as scenes i i would
appreciate that i think you know all the
i'll take it it's crazy because when you
think about it what they mainly did at
marvel what they mainly did at the
marvel panel
was go over a lot of things we have
already heard about
like
like a lot of it was mainly confirmation
yeah you know yeah like kang dynasty was
a big one that i i do feel bad if that
was their original intention to release
it on saturday and not d23 if they did
originally i feel bad that they got
leaked the day before that's a bummer
um and i think that is a really big one
but they mainly did is confirm give us a
couple of cool trailers
and you know they got some exclusive
hall h footage that is of course leaked
now on the internet according to a bunch
of comments that have been coming in
but i wonder what that d23 will be the
crazy one but it's cool how like marvel
they can just confirm [ __ ] or noun [ __ ]
and then she's like they just blow the
blow the doors open yeah we're thinking
about making this eventually oh my god
but shazam t i like this shazam two
trailer a lot and just for thrown out
for dc i thought i thought it was a
great trailer james adams will smith is
heading over to smack you as we speak
briar byron howes
hey in phase six do you think deadpool 3
or any mutant solo projects will appear
obviously not an x-men movie or x-men
team
uh yeah it's a deadpool 3
at least i would be surprised if
deadpool 3 wasn't part of the multiverse
i mean the thing that would break the
internet is announcing an actual x-men
movie but i think we will get some type
of mutant based
sho i feel like we'll get a disney plus
show yeah
um
not an x-men show but something about a
mutant
cyclops yes the jubilee [ __ ]
the juggernaut i'm the juggernaut [ __ ]
christmas special
well when's it when's marvel's coming
out marvel's is
uh first quarter of 2023
and that would be or no mid 2023 july
28th okay so we're not like a year away
almost exactly damn yeah that will have
mutants by the way sorry
unfortunately we got she-hulk coming and
then black panther two and then that's
the end of phase four
because if we got because there's a
storyline that involves rogue with the
marvels and i thought that would be cool
to include but oh well i don't think
it's gonna happen maybe maybe someday
coy is in the stream where did you just
wake up coy coy
you wake up
how are you doing everybody wants
another koi's comic corner koi you
better get over here today and film yeah
come on [ __ ] produce i got billion
ideas for you of what to do you're gonna
film non-stop i'm gonna put you to work
yeah like a slave monkey's [ __ ] can't
do it
theorize coins they rank this recommend
a comment do it coy go all right but
talk less i don't want to edit forever
dance but only for a certain specific
time period
gal warshot hello to israel thank you
for joining us and sheikh muhammad ali
hello to pakistan thank you for joining
us as well uh
gulam which which one i'm gonna throw
this to the chat i got a kind of a
negative question jump on it which one
do you which one of these marvel
announcements do you think
will be
[Music]
the least popular will be will not be a
big hit which one do you think will be
the least popular out of every one that
has been announced
gula mula there's also a february 2024
slot open likely dp3 there's also two
more movies in 2025 february and july
four movies 2026 rest of the spots on
phase four um phase six slate are all
shows as movies have exact dates locked
up ha
ha i was i was on to something
oh that's a good point
maybe that is that is exactly what you
were sort of talking about i don't know
man they shift [ __ ] all the time they
ship [ __ ] around all the time oh yeah i
mean i feel like the dates now will be
more solid than the dates of phase four
have been but yeah and sometimes they
announce a movie that they turn into a
show yeah and i bet that they're waiting
to see how some of these things go in
phase four of whatever needs to be
adjusted so then they can finalize the
six slate they do i think that's the
thing when you have this much going
sometimes you do need a little bit of
breather to
not completely redo your plans but to
recalibrate a little bit so that is kind
of the concern when you're announcing so
much as opposed to because once the end
what's the last year that they announced
up to
2026 2026 is the is the next avengers
movie the last avengers movie they
announced up to let's see
date is november 2025 2025. so that's
like [ __ ]
they got to like shoot all this in two
years yeah they got all this has to be
shot at least within two years you know
a mutant and tall anthology show david
mckay saying in the show would actually
be cool to set up each character i would
like an hour to hour and a half episode
per character yeah that would be so cool
so essentially if like i don't know
movies
that would be pretty cool oh where is
the punisher i don't know but as the
street level character i don't know
punisher is so violent that you gotta
wait till marvel can go super r rated
like i don't think we're gonna see
punisher for a while yeah
there's a lot of things to to figure out
with that in his mcu the punisher
more than blade
by far is so much more viable because
there's so there's not the whimsy
there's not the like genre height
because you would yeah it's just about
like trauma and real world violence yeah
real world like yeah [ __ ] veterans
like the scenarios the war battles
yeah yeah yeah and police and all sorts
of stuff like there's yeah and it's a
politically subversive comic and and i
feel like if people already have enough
trouble swallowing some of captain
america movies ideas we're gonna have to
work on that the thing though is is like
even if it takes a few more years
i really hope they preserve john
preserve job earth i'll keep him people
frozen
cryo chamber
john bernthal reserve preserve the burn
though preserve the burn i i think john
bernthal is just the perfect punisher um
yeah
in every universe
yeah he is perfect i like ray stevenson
i really hope that they do they do keep
him like i pray i'm praying that they
keep the burnt off because you know like
even if he's like
that's the thing with john bernthal um
or the punisher frank castle himself is
that even if he comes back and he's
definitely like looks older than the
last time we saw him that that works for
the punisher yeah like kind of an aged
wizard
it works it works for the punisher if he
is like older and stuff you know i like
that i mean it'd be harder on john
bernthal's body to do all that yeah he's
influenced you know he can do it he
wants to he wants it
bunch of worlds
uh words worlds hi thank you so much
to be so passionate about movies i feel
less alone you're the reason i learned
english i'm french oh that's amazing
that's so cool i'm sure we're not the
only reason you learned english but that
would be very poorly in french in
college otherwise i would i would say
something
to you
endearingly that is part of the fun of
having a a channel especially doing the
lives with you all is because um you
know like we're in la where so many
people talk about movies and shows all
the time like it's such a big part of
the culture
yeah everyone's a reviewer so uh
when you when you do the channel like
this you see people from all
places from the world you know like
right now i'm seeing gal in here uh
who's from israel and and you know you
got yourself a bunch of worlds from
france and then beyond like
international countries you know you got
people in all different states
too where the community of film or even
even talking about marvel just like
something that's more specific
is just not as vast so to be able to do
this and connect with a bunch of people
from across the globe is always one of
the highlights especially of doing a
live stream yeah mel
mace harris i'm looking forward to
captain america new world order and
blade and of course the two new avengers
movies i think
c captain america four should be a
perfect underdog rocky style superhero
movie
i feel like we've covered a lot of that
ground and falcon in the winter soldier
though yeah he runs up the steps and
does the whole thing he had a training
montage he had a rocky montage there
mancini music yeah
uh i mean
in a way i feel like there is a certain
amount of that that you would expect or
maybe require of the movie version you
know because you're jumping back into
the movie format and you've got to
imagine some people out there will not
have seen
the falcon omer soldier show but uh but
yeah i do agree we've kind of already
done that and i would feel like
i don't know i would want to see him in
a bit more of a confident place at the
top i think
this version of captain america i think
they gotta really put him through the
ringer in this movie yes it has to be
like
how john wick suffers in you know in
these films or or how
uh charlie cox's daredevil was suffering
in the first couple episodes of the
daredevil show on netflix you know where
like physically suffering and always
having to physically recoup like they
really got to capture the human
side of him
and not like really i think i we're
really hoping for that movie is that
they lean into the fact that he is human
and now he's taking up the task and the
mantle of someone who was super human
and you know that that has to be the
thing that where it's a mental endurance
and and having to overcome something
mentally as he pushes his body
physically through the ringer on
situations where he just can't heal as
well it doesn't have as much strength to
do stuff you know i think that's what
this movie should really capture without
i'm hoping i'm really hoping they do
because that would just make you root
for him that much more and if he could
have the line of like i can do this all
day at the very end you know where it's
like what like whoever's whoever's
yelling at him like you're just yeah
you're just a man you can't do this yeah
and he says i can do this all day when
you're just being like man he's really
[ __ ] up like this he's really pushing
through right now he might not be a
super soldier but he has the heart and
intellect of the
super soldier
that would be amazing ghost 8386 says
jody comer for mystique
interesting what did happen to the iron
patriot iron patriot show
what did happen there i don't know man
uh nathan kaufman
years ago marvel hit captain america
civil war's real title with the serpent
society do you think they are misleading
us with any of these new world order
sounds a bit iffy i could be wrong
i mean
no
i could imagine some of these titles
changing because like house of harkness
became covenant of chaos but i feel like
they went to the trouble of announcing
these in hall h with actual graphics
they had made so i feel like for the
most part the titles are probably pretty
solid and two i mean new world order
given that captain america movies are
often geopolitical in some way i feel
like that to me makes a lot of sense as
a subtitle and you know borrowing from
the comics and other stuff like that but
you know there's always a conspiracy
theory in our real world about the new
world order so i feel like that makes a
lot of sense shouts out to monkey's
comment wolverine just needs to be short
like he is in the comics not over six
foot short guys can be heroes too short
kings
six
i'm shorter than your wheelchair
i'll slash your ankles
come over here
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah i want it i want it
darwin's kemp and then it shows up to
wolverine pick on someone your own size
i've got several times my body mass
worth of strength jeffrey james
confidence sam wilson i could do this
most of the time
between the hours of 8 30 and 6 pm
that's a funny ass comment i can do this
most of the day
i love that coffee
darwin's kemp when do you think usage
will come back do you think we'll get
thunderbolts about the marvels at d23
definitely thunderbolts is when it's
coming back when the [ __ ] else ugly
kings hire more ugly kings yes
absolutely thunderbolts when we'll see
us agent for sure most def um
and yeah there will be some marvel's
stuff at d23
i think i think marvel's is when they're
definitely reserving some information i
don't know what more they can reveal
about it though
other than like this it's coming it's
coming but will they get a trailer or
something i don't i don't think so
they're just gonna come out on the stage
and be like guys let's pull back the
release you're gonna like carol danvers
more this time yeah see that post credit
scene how he thought she was kind of
funny yeah
i don't think armor wars is cancelled i
feel like they'd say something right
maybe
i feel like armor wars might be one of
those phase sixers
maybe
i don't know or maybe it got folded into
something else
yeah yeah we can copy my thoughts here
um
king marvel
what do you think we're gonna see
what do you think if we are gonna see dr
doom and black panda wakanda forever
what i'm thinking
is
um you know the because there's so many
things the the wakanda forever plot
didn't was really capturing the trailer
was only really capturing the
the feeling and the scope and and and
some
themes and the pain
that's what the trailer was really
capturing black panther what kind of
forever trailer but what we really
didn't dive too much into was the plot
of what we could be doing and there was
that very specific sequence they did
focus on
where they were pulling up something and
i got the vibe they were like awakening
neymar in some way so
i think if that we were to see black uh
black panther uh black tube black doom
black hat over here to see dr doom
in the post credit scene that somehow
he's involved with those people that's
what i'm thinking if they were searching
for neymar or god in the midst of things
you know wanting to get vibranium or
whatever like why are they going to war
it's obvious in the trailers they are
there's a war happening so why is the
war happening what is the
specific vendetta here
that
that uh you know the atlanteans name or
have with the people of wakanda yeah and
and somehow is was doctor doom a
contribution
to that that's the big question to me
well yeah and i feel like with with what
exactly like even saying it in the chat
it somehow
is benefiting from the war between them
oh yeah i could absolutely see that i
mean that would be a some prime
commentary and b it it would be very apt
for there to be some kind of initial
conflict between wakanda and atlantis
and
then you could have them kind of resolve
and become allies because they both are
you know in ways separated from the
world or at least what kind of was until
recently and uh they both are sort of
elemental and societies that you know
are very much harmonious with the land
so i feel like there's a lot uh to kind
of cross over between them they would
make very like apt allies
in that way um
uh yeah and a lot of people are
confirming in the chat that the uh armor
wars writer has confirmed it's still in
development so that should
still be happening and dakota jones
welcome thank you
uh nishai you're behind on the chat
uh thank you for quality efficiency that
last uh super chat there thank you
nishai uh khan definitely more than this
is loki going to be reintroduced in
avengers kang dynasty meta
no man no he's gonna be in loki too they
are doing the three you see johnny bring
back up to phase five phase five
pull up face five pull up phase five
okay so we got ant-man quantum mania
definitely see i feel like we're gonna
be weaving in and out with things that
are somehow like simultaneous some of
it's going to be like very king focused
yeah like loki ended on the note with
you know the the kang reveal like that's
what it ended on so season two is going
to have to carry on that king quality
king quality and ant-man quantomania
obviously king heavy in there he's the
main villain and i feel like some of
these have to somehow have a little bit
of dr doom in there so for example iron
heart you know i don't know like if they
would lean heavily into doctor doom but
iron heart being introduced in black
panther of wakanda forever if we assume
that doctor doom is going to be in black
panther wakan forever maybe the
post-credits scene
then perhaps
that would link it to iron heart in some
way i feel like there's going to be some
things in here that are like teasing
doctor doom because
you are building the two avengers movies
and i feel like secret wars is going to
be
dr doom heavy where did dr doom get his
doctorate from
um
phoenix arizona
the college of the canyons
yeah all right pizza boy 153 and then we
will do a refresh
it also took me several viewings of the
wakanda forever trailer not to tear up i
heard that the duffer brothers were in
talks with marvel do you think they
might be given the avengers movies holy
balls that would be crazy i'd be more
interested in them doing a show for
marvel yes agreed i think especially
since they're doing a show where it's
like they're doing like feature films
yeah
i don't think they could wrap this all
up in the movies i'm like you know is
any show going to be long enough how
like three-hour episodes each year yeah
how long would their movie be i don't
think they would be on the avengers for
the thing we talked about before is i
feel like like you're right they they
probably
look at the array of directors they have
across the phases of their current cycle
and they see who rises to the top in
order to kind of helm that but i think
the duffer brothers would be an
interesting especially as marvel heads
more towards the hellish characters in
the midnight suns part of the universe
that could be a really cool place to see
the duffer brothers do they think
absolutely i would love the duffer
brothers involved in marvel they have a
master class now i want to take their
message
master classes actually sound really
cool yeah
yeah i'm gonna get em we should get a
membership we should get kevin spacey's
master class i'm pretty sure that's
still up there it's gotta be it's on his
youtube channel if it's not he's
probably doing another one right now but
i think yeah exactly i think a lot of
people in the chat are definitely um you
know preferring
the duffer brothers for possibly a show
stephen apshire john marine that can
receive an abstract dr doom shows up in
a post-credits scene talking about
finding unlimited energy source and says
how we have to keep the retrieval team
small no more than four then bam back to
credits oh we got a lot of support here
super chess i really appreciate it
i was like oh man we're a little bit
behind here
most evil king is immortals
i would love it if if the kang dynasty
was just king for like one good gang
versus a bunch of other gangs it has
nothing to do with the avengers yeah
it's the biggest crossover event of only
one actor the only man who could stop
the threat isn't it
another bees across the multiverse
stepping
it would be like the agent smith fight
but with no neo just another agent smith
i would actually really love that and
then uh let me run a refresher her yeah
chloe should direct eternals too you
know what like i'm i'm fascinated by
that because i i feel like certain
directors in the mcu get a second shake
even if their first movie isn't like
greeted with the most warmth but then
certain directors don't get invited back
like you know alan taylor or the folks
who make captain marvel so like what is
what is the key there because i've been
wondering that like i feel like it's
cool that they got chloe zhao and she
seemed very enthused about that project
so part of me is like i would like to
see you come back and and you know build
on what she started there but i honestly
don't know if she would get that
opportunity or if she would want it now
we need some 3d man in the mcu mr
somerset
do it hungry gangs versus morbid time
they should just have more via versus do
it you cowards morbius versus bully
mcguire is what i say i want that i
think that sony would get
like so many clicks they would break the
internet if they did that where's the
logical follow to the shangshi post
credits scene the beacon from the rings
i feel like that's going to come in the
form of the marvels yeah bro and magson
um hey guys don't know if donkey kong if
you remember me
but nonetheless i miss your faces oh no
i'm way behind here oh we're so behind
what the fudge
um what's going on no we're not
no we no no no no no no here we are
we're not we got a fled we got adam
farnsworth
the dolphin cd from the good place the
dolphin hitler i do not condone the
actions of hitler oh no yeah so i've
misread your name i wasn't saying your
condition you're with him i appreciate
the follow-up with the stream left
though a dolphin hitter please do not
relate me to that man i don't i misread
it from a distance of where it's located
uh i'm purely warning about dolphin
violence against women as the respecting
woman lover i am good i appreciate that
women every day are being evicted
[ __ ] dolphins need to stop hitting
them
they all just pop out of the water
which is the worst dolphin sound
anyone's ever made bro and magson broon
hey guys toby dies in secret wars that
suck all right
i don't think that's the search i don't
want to go
he's got to be out there i gotta believe
billy mcguire is out there hey guys
don't know if you remember me but
nonetheless i miss your faces i'm glad
to see you guys
maxine well patron i miss our long
patron chats greg yes
but i'd love to see the actor
lothbrok uh travis famel
in the mcu in some capacity terrific
actor let's look up travis famel really
quick
travis just a big dick of travis now
pops up
oh my god what have we done all right
guy from warcraft over here look at this
sexy man oh this guy looks very i feel
like i've seen him in something else
yeah aside from vickings and uh well
let's look oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
warcraft
he's in rust best movie to be in
uh some other stuff yeah
i see a punisher i don't know if punish
is is punisher on disney plus right now
yes
i think go look up john ask ask josh
thank you bro max and i miss you too man
so yeah that's a good call what's josh
saying josh wants you to play doctor
doom
that's literally what it says is greg as
doctor doom so uh
you know start working on that lat
virion accent my guy i think you would
be a great doctor doom plus i would love
to see like your curly hair sticking out
from yeah i would love to be that doctor
i would love to play doctor
yeah be good i want to get my big fro
hair coming out because my hair falls
man
it's okay yeah yeah yeah you could just
be dr doom constantly having to break to
adjust his hair uh armin
leppo lipo
thank you for the memento de silencio
you are very kind uh
curly boy is what i'm gonna go with
i feel as dr doom will be in black
panther too in some way because maybe he
needs the vibranium for his suit
i can't i don't see punisher here
you guys lying about that i
it wouldn't make sense to me but then
again i think that they did they just
didn't know it is here i found it okay i
don't know why i was popping up earlier
okay yeah yeah
all right man maybe they'll take a shot
and we actually will get the puncher
i think it's just a different
association when you move the show over
but [ __ ] that'd be crazy yeah i think
when they're producing a new like
getting a show and placing it is
different as opposed to we're producing
something that's going to be hard r yeah
and we need people to you know [ __ ]
watch
but they don't really need you know what
i mean it's like a different thing
financial wise investment wise yeah
to move something over versus
we're gonna like literally start from
the ground here with this one you know i
feel like disney has a rare opportunity
at this moment i found it guys sorry the
chat is behind the chat is slower on
slow motes that's why i feel like
disney's found a rare opportunity to
basically go okay we just introduced
this age gate and we're gonna have more
mature content on our platform and i
think that like doing an r rated
punisher show or an ma rated punisher
show could bring in more new subscribers
because they probably haven't there's
probably something to be made up in
that audience for harder more adult
content
uh let's see here gabriel martinez armin
lippo thank you for the moment of
silence
uh see uh gabriel martinez yeah yeah
okay uh
did we do we did this one no that's no
colorboard yeah yeah oh we didn't finish
it no we didn't finish it vibrating for
suit also excited uh to see the iron
heart movie show
movie higher heart at
and i shouldn't have been i love you i i
think they should do moonlight interact
with the avengers but but then you find
out that it was all in his head it was
actually with the avengers that's what i
want by the way there's answering
commentary hello to venezuela gabriel
martinez
can you give two actors you want
or think to play galactus
i thought jon hamm would work
i actually think
they should bring back james spader
yeah
that'd be funny
and that would work and plus you had
like the giant uh you know ultron at one
point in the what if so like that would
be super cool if you just seem looming
but as galactus fully over a world yeah
i think that's it
great choice yeah i'm down somebody else
in the chat oh my gosh i think like a
[ __ ] john malcolm
there's a certain i like that that kind
of it was like thanos was like oh josh
rolling with a deep voice like you
associate that poor and i want one of
those
not so deep voice driven gig but i'm
here to devour your world
face
some people in the chat have said arnold
schwarzenegger for uh galactus that
feels you a good
planet i feel like his cheekbones is
just is yeah it would work but i like
that and thank you for the super chat
gabriel nameless king what does he what
do you like nameless king likes
pineapples and who the [ __ ] doesn't i
like a pineapple i also uh i love the
debate about pineapple on pizza and how
mad people get about that i love it so
much i did not know this was a debate
until very very recent when it was first
brought up in stranger things and i just
went oh
that must have been how people responded
to pineapple in the 80s
and i found out no this is a real thing
that people argue about and i've always
eaten pineapple on pizza and i've never
questioned it that's why you weren't
part of the conversation
until now mutants were introduced as
people questioning in the chat by the
way yeah
spoiler alert david harper as uh as as
uh collect collectors would be good too
pizza boy one five three also atlanteans
appear to be blue
possibly the sense of ancient cree
good call that crash landed
that's actually a really good call
possibly tied to the bengal in the 10
rings
could be cool
seattle i feel like maybe
yeah
they might but i feel like we might not
even explore that much it might have
just been a
aquatic choice
to associate with them
but it is possible it's a definite
possibility i could see them doing
something like that because i feel like
there is
a certain amount in our real world of
like did aliens yeah just have something
to do with places like atlantis or or
the pyramids or whatever so like they
could
yeah you're bound to have multiple blue
characters who's the guy what's the
actor's name who plays the concierge and
john wick
he's a black guy he's bald oh yes yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's like you know his name um
he could damn it he could be galactus um
no he would be a good galactus yeah yeah
yeah comment his name in the in the chat
if you know who we're talking about
pineapple on pizza is legitimate there's
a lot of that seems to have sparked the
most to me it always does that's the
thing
that's the thing
uh hey we should skip at the secret wars
in the theaters mm-hmm
leave the channel behind yeah for like
two months uh-huh hack people think like
what happened to these guys and just
come back with a reaction reaction
there you go the chronicles of reddick
all right pineapple canadian pizza best
canadian bacon on pizza is the best
thing ever
uh says somebody in the chat r073
thoughts on phase seven eight and nine
and beyond or does mcu end no they're
gonna they're gonna i think yeah
i think they're gonna leave all that
money on the toy
we're shutting down marvel studios now i
think we should go out on top guys um no
i think i think uh like to tie it into
what tyler summers saying i said it's a
few times around the chat you know like
tyler summer in the chat's asking sumner
where where do you think we see
moonlight next and i think it's gonna be
phase seven i really believe face phase
seven eight and nine
is uh you know like phase one through
three is the infinity saga phase seven
and phase four through six is multiverse
saga and i think seven eight and nine is
going to be called i think it'll be
called the supernatural saga but it's
gonna be called but it's gonna basically
imply that that's what we're dealing
with is the supernatural side so i think
that's that's when you can go into like
mephisto territory in hell and all that
marvel goes to hell will be the next
boss
the hell saga the hell saga
a legit fan thank you for the moment of
silence thank you armand lipo
do you think they will bring back
john bernthal's punisher
i feel like now that i've officially
learned that the punisher is on disney
plus yeah i think when the day comes to
bring back john bernthal's bring back
the punisher it's going to be jon
bernthal uber says clancy brown is
galactus that could be cool
gavin isla guys look there's no question
about it why are you guys arguing in the
chat about it if there's mutants or not
that's the whole breaking point of the
miss marvel ending there are mutants now
and pineapple is an okay pizza top yeah
gavin isla i would like to do a collab
with heroes of forge and blind wave both
heroes of forge more possible just
because of the fact that they live in
california it's much more possible
um
what was gavin thank you gavin he's lost
his super chat what's he asking do you
think
do you guys think the kang in ant-man
could be a mislead and dr doom is a
villain and he's a variant of kang in
the quantum city they will announce all
of that in that ant-man quantum mania
movie thus undermining the kang dynasty
directly
a full phase and a half in advance
no i i don't think that's the case at
all uh-uh i think i think they got a
they're setting up the variant kings you
know
and and i think this this is your
this is what you're building up to and
this is the start of truly building up
to it on the cinema side of it you know
loki handled the show and then now this
uh i i feel like that would be i would i
would honestly hate that
i appreciate any and all theories but i
would be very disappointed if that's the
case lance reddick on pizza i'm just
going to pin this to the top of the
channel shouts out to lance reddick yep
shouts out to lance reddick uh hey thank
you gavin's loss i'm going to highlight
you really quick so you get that uh
jordan von doom so dont i was trying to
think of a question and answer that
question of who could be a good secret
wars director
keep it a secret
what do y'all think
they'll do with the daredevil theme
loved the show's song but doubt they'll
keep it also what are you guys excited
for most kang wise that daredevil
opening theme music was fire
if i can i don't know what they'll do
for the daredevil theme song i don't i
have no idea
every show
like slide guitar the very hbo opening
the hbo um yeah
but in terms of
i i think
you actually said it on the phone call
with me yesterday
about why you're excited for jonathan
majors to be king and i think you should
reiterate that here oh yeah uh jonathan
majors yeah cause like in
loki just with one scene he was so
dazzling to watch and i feel like across
the mcu moving forward through these
next two phases we're gonna see him pop
up as so many different iterations of
this character that it seems like you
would like that would be a dream for an
actor to be able to do
so many different takes and and to be
able to surprise us and to be able to do
things that are maybe fun that are maybe
sinister that are maybe a little bit of
both and uh i yeah just i love watching
him and i get so excited for that
prospect of you know all the fun that
they're gonna have letting kang
you know really
unfold and stretch out over the next
couple of phases so yeah like that
that's a big exciting prospect to me
that's a good combination of i'm excited
because of the actor but i'm also
excited because of the character all
right um so yeah i'm just looking
forward to that that was something that
you really made me think about too
because i i just sort of thought like
you have he who remains and then king
yeah and i was like oh wait you're
probably gonna see like a bunch of
different versions it's like it's kind
of associated with you know how you got
oscar isaac as moon knight or
or or or james mcavoy in in the split
movies you know except you really get to
spend time with them per movie each
version and then you make a full
hardcore comedy the kang dynasty bunch
of kings living together it's gonna be
like an eddie murphy who clogged that
toilet yeah yeah i'm gonna travel back
in time and make sure you don't [ __ ] in
this toilet nutty professor with kangs
yeah yeah
exactly dude it's gonna be awesome
but yeah and then every time he shows up
the take can be a surprise and i think
that would be so cool because like think
of it like you see him show up after
whatever installment you're like oh [ __ ]
kang's coming something bad
but then they subvert you again and then
oh this king's a good game you know
thanks uh river for being a recent
citizen of the reject nation oh so i
think that uh jonathan majors especially
is
like he says something so cool in an
actor's round table he was like i don't
like to get roles if i don't audition oh
i want to make sure i've deserved the
role and i'm the right person for the
job i don't want to waste anyone's time
i'm like that's not what i ever hear
actors say
every actor is like i hate auditions or
not real it's not real acting and he's
like i want to make sure i'm the right
one for the job
you could argue it is real acting um
i wanted to see the marvel for them all
roommates i think it would be cool
there's a cane comedy awaiting us taika
get on it yes make the mcu happy daryl's
just living with kangs uh i love how the
tiger just takes one [ __ ] up for people
right taika
did uh yeah
people were like he saved thor
and then the small camp the minority was
i don't like this version yeah
he saved it made it amazing are they
gonna cancel the star wars movie and
then and then he does jojo wins an oscar
who like tiger's a saint
and and then he does
love and thunder and like now it's
flipped to like it's [ __ ] too much
comedy ruining thor
man the backlash
con con thank you khan well i got the
finally some of the question asked was
agatha disney plus explain what happened
to scar witch after doctor strange
i don't think so um i i don't think they
will
i kind of want them to not include
scarlet witch only because
you see you gotta do some leg work to
make sure people will care enough about
agatha and for her to have her own show
that
the the worrisome part with
cameos sometimes is that it'll
completely steal focus yeah you know if
the villain steals the show that's one
thing
if ralph boner steals the show
yeah oh my god sadie sink as rogue would
not be a bad pick at all i love that
i love that pick do it um
anyway yeah i think she'll return she's
definitely gonna return and maybe
perhaps d23 is reserving a scarlet wood
solo movie
you know she has amnesia
i'd do that plot scarlet identity
yeah
he wakes up in the water i'm looking for
my kids again oh no
we just did this
let me take you to the memory station i
don't think they will i appreciate that
broadway by ghostlight thank you for the
super chat love you guys
uh what do you make of the announce
finally someone's asking about the
announced animated shows not being
present in the phase 5 lineup that
is a hell of a question
that i have not even thought about
myself that is a great question
yeah because what if was part of the the
lineup uh of the announcements and so
holy crap wait what what year does phase
four end
and
bury's a great show
that season finale of season three was
one of the most intense moments of
television i've ever watched
john when does phase three and what is
the year uh it's this it's it's jesus
phase five when is faith time oh phase
five ends in
2023 i believe
let's go over here 24 sorry july of 2024
thunderbolts
but they already showed an episode uh is
there a blank spot on here where's the
blank spot
so there's no blank spot on 2025
i mean not on phase five
because they already they showed an
episode of what if season two meaning
they're already
like could've finished what if season
two so you can expect a release date
by next year i'm assuming yeah and if
it's not part of then then it kind of
rendered that then that whole thing you
know with spider-man
um
freshman year
really doing its own thing makes a lot
more sense to me
if it's not actually part of the canon
but then i'm like but i thought what if
was part of the canon so are you not
taking away what if see that from the
canon like what's going on here that
bums me out uh because part i was very
excited that what if would have
something to do with the canon and i
think in all these multiverse movies
there's always one drawn animated
universe at least so i'm like yeah i
think that would be great to have as
part of it i don't know if they're just
trying to go hey
we're separating out our
media of animated versus live action but
i don't know i think
in some ways it would be a bummer not to
have them be canon
uh but i would want to hear more about
why they chose that because yeah at
first spider-man freshman year was like
this is going to be directly related to
tom holland in the mcu and now it seems
like that's not really the case so and
then x-men i feel like that would the
one thing that seems good about that is
i feel like x-men 97 continuing
that might muddy the canonical water for
x-men in the main mcu and two i mean
canon or not you could just say it's
another multiverse that we're not seeing
you know
effects from on the main timeline
um
marcus in the chat saying austin butler
is gambit that is a good choice
i think that would be
a perfect choice he should always play
those kinds of characters
model model if bucky barnes ends up in
thunderbolt so you think his turn will
happen in cap four
no
i mean no no no i mean i mean i think i
don't think they're going as hardcore
and thunderbolts as people expect
because
in thunderbolts they are like dark
avengers you know public likes them at
first
but you find out they're
they're not good people
but i think they're going to be more
like
you know the the band of misfits
you know
some suicide squadish yeah where by the
end you're like they're not that bad
they're dysfunctional and there's
probably a better application for them
than this but yeah yeah i don't think
it's gonna be that
that way i feel like they're gonna keep
bucky on the church because he's already
gone through like hardcore villainy
terms i don't want him to be a villain
again yeah sheldon hickman
love you guys i'm watching both you and
campy right now that must be hard to
process i would love it if we our our
dialogue just happened to sync up with
campy is at one point
yeah you know
tune into the john campio show and then
uh let us know if he's saying what we're
saying right now
who do i want to play jubilee um the
girl from uh uh everything everywhere
all at once the daughter of michelle
yeah stephanie shu yeah yeah dude i
think should be a good one irfan yusof
hello tupac is pakistan it's good to
have you with us okay yeah thank you
sheldon for that yeah uh
a cologne i heard some people were they
got a
i heard some people were disappointed
that it was king in the new ant-man and
not doctor doom
we've heard forever that it's going to
be king they've yeah confirmed they
confirmed that a d23 like a year ago uh
personally i'm excited for him your
thoughts love you i mean what i'm
excited to find out is is this kang
going to be is that your phone john
that's ringing obnoxiously right now
what i'm curious to find out right now
is um
will that kang be
the
the kang that bleeds through the mcu
like how how hog wild are they gonna go
that's called kang dynasty which implies
you know
kings yeah it's feels feels like it
could be plural
but i'm some weren't wondering if will
that kang be the king that bleeds
through the rest of the mcu or that king
like
get defeated and then we get another
king in loki season two or something you
know yeah like what that's where i'm
curious of what they're gonna do with
ant-man quantum mania i just hope every
kang that we see is increasingly a
little bit bigger than the last one
physically oh wait wait did we misread
it
okay because uh shinra in the chat say
no no they were disappointed that he
wasn't blue not that it wasn't doom
oh oh he's a different color
kang i mean yeah he's blue sometimes
i mean
he could they could change up the color
palette that's the benefit of having
barry who remains
the one we got here but i mean we're
going to hang in so many different
iterations that they've got
like they they keep doing classic suits
and they keep doing suits like they'll
do a take yeah especially if they just
unveiled the high evolutionary not in
full prosthesis but clearly there's
prosthesis there like i think they'll do
something classic with that
random do you guys think we're going to
get any mutants in f4 news at d23 i
think we're gonna get a fantastic four
casting announcement and i do think
mutants for sure we're gonna hear
something we gotta hear something can
you imagine they announced that the
unkenny x-men i don't think they're
gonna announce x-men but if they
announced that
i'd love to be wrong i want to help
lower expectations
that way we blow the roof open yeah
that's what that's the role i serve here
at the channel yes
intentionally getting inaccurate
predictions
yeah and then and then if somebody
steals it then you'll know because i'm
the kind of guy who i embrace when i'm
wrong on these things it makes life more
exciting for me it's a chance to learn
something new
his mask imagine if i came on this
stream and i was like
no let me let me try to justify why
marvel was actually disappointed
let me tell you why
okay a lot of people in the chat are
saying the kang isn't actually blue but
his mask uh the the visor makes his face
look blue so they might do that in the
movie
so we'll see i want to get too caught up
in it well we should mister you will
just wait
i'm excited for the prospect of more
team-ups young avengers west coast
avengers midnight suns alpha flight god
squad eta
god squad's got to be on the horizon i
mean i want to see what they'll do for
their smaller teams what i'm interested
in with the avengers is
you know
like they are building to
you see
how would i put this okay face i'm just
really efficient when i say this phase
four for some people have been kind of
confused on like what's this all
ultimately building to like who's big
baddie what's going to happen here right
some people have been have questions
about that because as much as people
will be like hey you know it took marvel
like several
movies and years to get to the infinity
war movie you know but i'm like oh no
but phase one was really simple to
follow it's you got you're setting up
these characters to come to it wasn't
even really about who were they gonna
fight it was more about
we're gonna see these characters share
the screen together for the first time
you know like it's gonna be a unique
movie experience so the build up and
then the payoff was over the course of a
couple of years it was really fast and
really easy to see with that one post
credit scene of we're putting a team
together with with nick fury saying that
and
back to this question of of of the
avengers i'm
like i'm thinking about the lineup you
know like you're gonna have like shaun
chi in there you're gonna have captain
marvel there you're gonna have
a bunch of different characters because
even avengers end game while you had
this big you know opening of portals and
infinity war had a bunch of characters
in there that you were hop between
guardians doctor strange all these
characters the avengers end game was
mainly focused on the og avengers then
you got a bunch of cameos at the end
infinity war you didn't see guardians of
doctor strange and iron man and cap and
all them together in the same room you
know
that big circle shot
here
like this is gonna be the first time you
see a bunch of these characters
sharing the screen together yeah and
that to me is really exciting you know
if they can get like
all the disney plus the disney plus
characters
and and then the movie characters all in
secret wars like how awesome is that
going to be if you see them all in the
same room technically all cgi is in the
same room because you know what marvel
does
of course of course all green screened
into the same room i'm seeing people say
that paul sorvino has passed away what
is that the case is that real
rest np i've seen a few people two good
fellows this year rest in peace pulsar
damn i'm gonna watch repo
great performance in there too singing
the operatic voice that man had rest in
peace who's a great actor yeah i love
the story he tells of good fellows of
how he discovered the villain because he
didn't know how to play it
and then one day he said
he tells us sort of quite a bit of like
he caught a glance of himself in the
mirror and was kind of spooked by his
own look
and that's how he realized this is how i
can play the character off of his own
reflection that he caught unexpectedly
oh cool yeah oh damn i have to listen to
that to listen to him tell the story
some of you guys expectations are wild
luke the grey man was great i don't know
what you're talking about that's what we
said in our review too everyone's dying
this year i know mr
blevin s15
uh thank you was it the depiction of
kingpin or his shirt i feel like people
were more bothered by the shirt
no i think it was the depiction it was
it was the trader joe's staff member
t-shirt it was in the way how it it felt
like he was little
yeah i didn't i wasn't a big fan of the
depiction overall of kingpin yeah and
then to put the tone of what vince's
inaugural goes for
in the
more lighthearted whimsical world that
hawkeye was embodying on christmas it
just didn't work and it didn't feel
scary and it felt kind of like a joke
yeah so i wasn't a fan of kingpin and it
seemed to be clashing
with what the hawkeye show was well
because they made such a big deal out of
like no no it's him and it's the one
you're thinking of and then nothing like
this show is like that show and the way
we're gonna handle this character is not
really like that and yeah and then now
it kind of feels like a different
character so
yeah i feel like they need a little
course correcting
sydney sweeney as emma frost sounds good
not gonna happen she's already in madame
webb uh dalton kane
wonder if kang dynasty speeds up
incursions due to his role in loki and
he stands in for beyond her and doom
takes his power for secret wars maybe
the end of doctor strange and thor like
in the comics
there's got to be some i mean that's as
good a theory as any that i've heard so
far
incursions and all that stuff are
definitely going to happen and and i
feel like there's a definite possibility
that you'll get yeah like a swap of
something other characters would have
done applied to kang and then maybe yeah
some kind of doctor doom clash there i
don't know that seems like like a likely
salad that we might have in some
configuration
i really i'd be the way how some people
felt would like not getting mephista was
disappointing like to me i could move on
i was able to move on from that really
fast even though i kind of expected it
i think
that if we don't get doomed that would
be the most this especially when the
fact you're getting fantastic four
introduced yeah not that i think doom
needs to be in the fantastic four movie
but it would be cool
um and you know uh
i got cardiki here saying that you
really want to meet us both to have a
long combo it's like a dream hey i'll
say this that if you ever see us on the
street come say hi we're more than happy
to talk with anyone luke we're gonna
watch nope at some point i don't know
that probably not a review now that the
movie's out but uh but rest assured it
will be seen
the most anticipated movie right now and
i've heard it's great on imax someone um
someone brought covenant in this moment
had to skip a screening i
hate whoever did that to us
yeah i hate them
i hope they die this year where
everyone's dying
it was interesting to not lie
i've covered i can't go
yeah yeah yeah
what would the live that's what i want
to know
i mean i'm just saying yeah
i've used the code excuse before i was
exposed to some of the code i probably
shouldn't go out i probably just yeah
this time i just
actually was like oh [ __ ] i really got
it no man did i track this um
rachel h rochelle h thank you love you
so much thank you and rest in peace
david warner jose rodriguez thank you
for the super chat do you think hugh
jackman may return his wolverine no we
gotta move on from that he's not going
to return his wolverine multiversal
cameo sorry to tell you nothing
substantial sorry
jennifer armstrong
love you guys love you more armstrong i
love your last name that was the name of
our first teacher
mrs
armstrong yeah thank you crazy eyes mrs
armstrong thank you all for your videos
thank you for your support
loyal citizen
kepler137 will ferrell as doom a one-off
killed by captain marvel
if we get a variant
that would be great that would be
they should put jonathan majors in white
face
yes
that would be that always works he's the
white version
white gang i would love it if if will
ferrell shows up as dr doom and then is
immediately killed
falls down out of frame and the real
serious doctor doom is there yeah
that's what i want
uh and yes d23 expo marvel reveals will
be fun scott gustin if hall h was fun
then you gotta imagine that uh d23 is
gonna be even funner see rick all points
out i mean i think king dynasty will
show what he who remains explained to
loki and sylvia about his variants being
at war with each other that's what i
mean i think kang dynasty can bring all
that [ __ ] together just like king versus
kang vs kang versus king versus kang vs
kang versus kang gucci kang gucci kang
gucci kang gucci
when do you think they will start the
new spider-man trilogy what do you mean
it's going we got ourselves craving the
whole animal lover animal lover
we got young hot madame webb yes
well you know i mean milfs can be like
30 years old and up now yeah man dude
she [ __ ] he's a hot ass madame webb
what i think of is that [ __ ] dakota
johnson i saw 50 shades and i'm like we
got to get madame webb going madame webb
sydney sweeney that's what i think of
when i think of madame
yeah what else is there to say masked
spider hey greg and john do you think
doom will be introduced in a baron zemo
type of role in wakanda forever maybe
trying to have atlantis and volcano go
to war while he does some
behind-the-scenes stuff
um i don't think
the i think the reveal doom in like a
post-credits scene was somehow involved
in the start of the war i don't think
we're going to see him because like zemo
was was very integral
throughout civil war
you know
uh he really wanted to see the blue in
capsize
but
that won't be the case here i think they
need to keep this more focused because
they also have to do so much more
lifting than just mcu [ __ ] for black
panther you know that that's going to be
so different than most of these marvel
movies because there's something very
real applied to that film yeah that a
lot of people that that has to be
handled with such delicacy you know yeah
exactly oh hey red hot chili peppers in
the chat
no way i see red hot chili peppers this
sunday super spreader concert
it's okay it's okay
that'll be worth it i'm so excited for
you even still like because now because
now i'm sitting here going okay i gotta
make sure that i'm um super locked down
so that when gorillas comes in september
then i'll take my one risk for the money
but yeah i'm sorry i'm very excited for
you oh i'm going to keep my mask on the
whole time and uh will ferrell is the
drummer in the 838 universe most
definitely akash d
you guys the best love you from india
dude i love you in india following the
indians discovered us first yeah then
our
reaction would be huge yeah that's right
as somebody in this chat said kang vs
crang
i like it
the carbon outlaw with the domino's
pizza avatar what do you think of
pineapple on pizza bob odenkirk is doom
yeah that would be cool with definitely
i'd actually be down for that somebody
said flea is modok
i think that would be great with two new
avengers movies being announced i think
this is the perfect opportunity for
marvel to bring the russo brothers back
well do i have a clip for you
[Laughter]
with kevin feige he did confirm uh and
deadline shared the video him basically
saying we love the russo brothers they
love us but they are not involved we
want to find something else to work on
but it is not this
so
i mean those uh
brothers just be [ __ ] exhausted yeah
and i bet they wanted i mean clearly
they want to do something other than the
avengers and gaming like you can you got
to imagine being in the russo brothers
shoes imagine look what
before we all knew joss whedon was a
total [ __ ] weirdo
but
imagine like what happened which it just
takes one movie to [ __ ] up all your
goodwill
like the russo brothers joss whedon did
the first avengers the people were like
ah
this is everything and then they did he
did age of ultron i'm like what the [ __ ]
happened what is this
this is a mess look what happened with
taika recently you know like look how he
talks about this movie in interviews he
didn't care he cut out so many good
things he hates the vfx artist you know
like all this [ __ ]
so the whole public persona in marketing
is always sarcastic yeah no i'm just
saying that like it takes one movie yeah
the russo brothers winter soldier
knocked it out the park a lot of people
hail that as the best mcu movie civil
war avengers 2.5 did an amazing job then
they got the ultimate task helming two
avengers movies back to back that also
have to serve as the culmination of
phase one through three and they nailed
it they did a great job they like
despite what you know there might be
some subjective opinions in here that
are not big fans of those movies the
majority really were satisfied with it
that is a a major task so not only do
they have to put in the work the hours
of editing directing mapping out working
with cast right like everything there's
also the
emotional and mental pressure to deliver
on this film that they just endured for
years to make sure they could nail this
i'd imagine that they'd be like to step
back into that i i
i don't know i'd be like i think we did
our thing
and now it's time to say bye
because
you know
all it takes for them to step back in
once and [ __ ] it up and be like i know i
[ __ ] it up yeah i would rather see
them come back and do something that's
outside of the stylistic box i'm used to
seeing them in for the mcu
um but yeah but yeah so jj abrams did
force awakens people loved force awakens
they did and then [ __ ] he does rise
skywalker and like [ __ ] this guy
and then uh you know even like paul
greengrass got crap for he did two great
bourne movies and then he does the
fourth jason bourne movie and a lot of
people didn't really like that film i
know you did but a lot of people didn't
even that guy i'm not about to say it's
the one i would want to watch
immediately first yeah harold says kevin
spacey is doom i like it uh mckenna gray
says spider-gwen is a no-brainer says
jesus
not a bad call for real kevin spacey
thumbs down uh roboto massive [ __ ]
super chat here thank you dear my god oh
my and i think uh if i'm not mistaken
you got dudes okay so yeah we're gonna
oh yeah we'll we'll join them together
thank you roberta that's a really big
super chat
i
still can't believe they just dropped
the avengers titles like that i think
it's like
remember how they marinated us with the
marketing for endgame we didn't know the
title until
that's true they do they really they
really like there's a clue here in this
photo that this spells endgame oh that's
so true you're you're absolutely right
about that and that was after the teaser
was dropped in that's right when they
had dropped the trailer remember the day
we watched it we didn't know what the
title was when we clicked on it yeah and
we um reacted to it um
what is marvel doing
they wanted to clear some [ __ ] up and i
i think i really don't think they wanted
to i don't think they wanted to reveal
the title i i don't think they want to
reveal the title
um but because that leak happened i
think they had to take ownership of it
that's the best way you handle leaks a
lot of the time she's got to take
ownership of it
and then uh roberto followed up with
john why don't you read it are they
desperate to keep people around or just
trying something new also 12 projects in
one year has me concerned i'm in the
boat of i'm too invested can't back out
now i'll watch but my interest isn't
there as much
you see there's a this is an interesting
conversation because
a lot of people um i would keep it on
the other one i think the other one is
more of the conversation to be had
thanks sean
i think this is an interesting
conversation to have because i do see a
lot of people i don't quite
weirdly i normally would be the person
who agrees with this but i'm a marvel
shill they write me checks once a week
you know um
is is there like marvel's
focus on quantity not quality
that's what a lot of people say now
right moral focus on quantity not
quality
and yeah they have a much larger
quantity
and i think there's been some real ups
and downs with their quality but i think
phase four has given us a lot of great
things
yeah you know and they are trying some
stuff out and a lot of it hasn't been
fully sticking the landing and at the
same time like i just said right now in
the chat someone just said the quantity
of quality you know um
and they are then their demand is higher
and they and they've had the
the difficulties of
covid creating delays not just with the
release dates but also backing up the
vfx artists and then there's this high
demand for great vfx but but they're
stacked everything's just so stacked so
it's hard and
you know the cgi department of vfx that
that's kind of a problem in the business
of hollywood in tot in total you know so
like warner brothers have been delaying
the warner brothers dc products they
don't have as many going and they've
been delaying their stuff so they can
make sure their vfx looks great whereas
they got such a big game plan here that
for them to shift one movie or two
movies just creates this whole mess for
them so things like that i gotta stick
to this plan so i don't think they're
like
sometimes we say quantity over quality
it's it can sometimes sound like they're
just like [ __ ] it throw it out people
will watch it you know but i don't get
the sense of that often times with these
disney plus shows it can just be a mixed
bag like that third episode there's a
couple episodes in hawkeye that i
thought were genuinely
great
moon knight i wasn't a big fan of the
finale but i thought so much of that
show was amazing and and certainly
demonstrated very strong quality
uh they gave us one division which was
like brought back event tv and when
streaming has such a hard time doing
week to week event tv
loki did that as well there's been a lot
of great things and they've had some
duds and you've had some things that
just didn't quite hit and some things
that felt rushed or like they could use
another writing pass or whatever
but um i i don't think it's an issue of
i do think that sometimes they do need
to slow down and be like hey hey
i i don't think the focus is on lack i
don't think they're lacking quality i
think i do think sometimes though they
do need to slow down and be like maybe
we need another pass at this or we need
to think this through does that make
sense well yeah because i feel like when
you say quantity over quality that is
like [ __ ] it just make it yeah and i
never see any of these and think oh they
clearly did
try or or or gave themselves nowhere
near enough time like i think what you
run into a lot of the time is
they are on a schedule and these
schedules are very rigid and they can
change but it's a big deal to change
them and so sometimes
i would imagine certain projects in the
tandem are going smooth and on schedule
and are looking great and other ones
maybe need a little more time and can't
get the benefit of that and so yeah i
mean
we're we're
three phases if you just look at the
infinity saga there's already a bunch of
stuff and i feel like just naturally
we're all used to the mcu now it's not
there are ways to make it fresh but
we're all used to it now and so i feel
like there was gonna be a certain amount
of just that phenomenon anyway
it is interesting to note this now
because in the past year we've had
more marvel in one window of time than
ever um and that's a real thing but yeah
each show and movie i've watched i'm
like i can see what they're going for
usually what they're going for is unique
to this character unique to this show
they're shared elements but each one has
its own identity sometimes the
identities work better than others but
yeah
it doesn't feel the same as when people
say that netflix goes for quantity over
quality
and i know that netflix has you know
certain aspects of their approach which
is you know give people creative freedom
and all that stuff but you know like
they do seem to be like let's just take
a bunch of money and make a ton of [ __ ]
so people come here
whereas marvel i i feel like everything
is so planned that nothing feels like
rushed in that way
yeah or quality quantity over quality
that way i agree like doctor strange
there's a middle chunk of that movie
that i'm not a fan of
and i did think the illuminati handling
was other than like wanted like [ __ ]
them all up and like that whole sequence
there's a lot i liked about doctor
strange for sure there's a lot of real
other stuff i absolutely loved about
that movie with their stuff but
definitely parts i'm like this could
have used a longer runtime
thor love and thunder second viewing
especially wasn't the
didn't hit me as like i i think a lot of
times we're left with a lasting
impression but let's not forget like
phase four gave us you know shang chi
which was
a great like
like a new direction for the amps like a
hat's traditional mcu
structure but also something so
different
and the other part too spider-man no way
home is
for some reason now
you know when you bring that up when you
bring up spider-man no way home they're
like
yeah we got spider-man in my home but
this is a sony film not really marvel
and i'm like oh now it's a sony yeah
yeah okay have you seen it have you seen
a pure sony film
when things go wrong is always my father
it's like a pure sony movie yeah is
[ __ ] you know um the morbius movies
look at the venom movies
those are those are different those
that's just sony
mcu marvel feige is so involved with
that with those with especially with no
way home they had like a different rule
to how they were gonna handle this one
right where was way more mcu involved so
much more feigy involvement with this
one around and i remember like seeing
fight like that was the time that koi
introduced us to kevin feige and i
remember
telling him
like
i talked to him for like 30 seconds
and and it was like a not a bit there
wasn't a lot of people there it was like
this small little hotel spot yeah it was
like a hotel bar yeah i talked for like
30 seconds and and i told him
like honestly i think people are really
gonna love this movie after watching no
way home and he was like
really you think so i know like yeah
he's like oh that's so good to hear like
there was like this weird like relief
i'm like you don't even know the [ __ ] i
am and you're like taking my word for it
this is your most obvious slam dunk but
you could see just how much he takes on
the pressure to make sure this movie's
gonna deliver and the people are going
to love it yeah and so my point with
that is like they gave us [ __ ]
spider-man no way home in this space
like this movie was amazing
um and that was so monumental so
uh i think the phase four has had just a
lot of great things and i don't think a
lot of
and and the takeaway lately has been
some of these other projects that just
have left a lot of people a little more
disappointed as all you know you got one
division and low-key it's been a long
time i got a big super chat there and
there so i want to spend some time with
that where's the in between yes right
there
uh thank you roberta cs phase six well
thank you ses phase six will intro x-men
proper to be ready for
uh secret wars the animated properties
will probably be included in secret wars
daniel's for fantastic actually the
daniels brothers for fantastic four
would be
a nice way to experiment if they don't
hold them back yeah
although but it might be a little too
much for your introduction it's like
sometimes you feel like they got to play
it safe
so they don't [ __ ] this up
the problem is that the daniels would
need to to do their thing and i feel
like you don't necessarily give people
like that the flag
a flagship you would give them more of a
ringer or some character that you're
introducing to more people that like
even if you haven't seen a fantastic
four movie read a fantastic four comic
you know who they are and their
expectations so i as much as i would
love that as much as i would i think to
myself this would be like the crazy
whimsical emotional version of what josh
trank tried to do probably like it's
probably going to hone in on like the
weirdness of just existing in these
different fantastical ways uh i would
love it but yeah i feel like a more
obscure character or a more left of
center property is probably what they
would get
um but yeah lars von trigger is
fantastic for i love that seattle ko but
yeah i think we should definitely make
that happen the the x-men will be ready
for sex work
sex
cosmo
i think we'll get a full-fledged x-men
movie in phase seven
if you're gonna do like
a full-fledged x-men movie then secret
wars immediately after i don't know
about that but i do think
ah god i'm not sure
don't worry mark asked twain uh josh
trank directed that uh al capone i mean
this the secret wars comic book is just
such a
it's such a very crazy story yeah that i
don't i think they're only to do chunks
of it
that would make sense i don't think they
can go full on
because
it's not going to it's not going to
resemble exactly that comic it's
impossible
it would have to be in a movie it seems
like it would be hard to just do the
entire yeah it's different when you got
decades of comics built up you know and
decades of story lines
uh where is here it's
just it would be close to two decades by
then but yeah like it's not the same
hundreds of issues
per character
yeah it's a totally different thing
we're in the infancy of this cinematic
universe cosmo cosmo the dog hope y'all
are feeling better been in the reject
nation since civil war and when i was
like 12. wow now i'm going to college in
a month appreciate y'all for real oh
dude go get some weed go get some
education get some tissues get some
tissues
touch yourself when your roommate is
you know sleeping yes and uh yeah keep
whatever whatever you guys do in college
yeah
you just you just tiptoe around each
other
you just find clandestine ways of taking
care of your business around your
roommates so yeah thank you
good luck i remember that civil war
trailer because that was the i think
that was the trailer where i completely
forgot to load i forgot to cut out the
part when i couldn't get the trailer
loaded
and i didn't know how youtube editor
worked and i still haven't cut that part
out of the trailer reaction all these
years yes but i didn't know how
to uh i didn't know how to do it i just
didn't know how to do it i think there's
still like this two minutes of me just
quietly loading the trailer that's real
that's real though that's good
sorry i won't do better call saul
reactions that shows just for me and i
love the [ __ ] out of the breaking bad
universes be very serene reactions i
think
i don't know man this is the last couple
episodes of breaking bad i've have been
so intense uh i better call saul
superman i'm glad to hear that
college reader nice advice grants
defense college right
hey felipe 100 convinced that doom sent
the troops we see in the trailer and
he's the real villain of black panther
ii we don't find out who sent them till
the end or post
see
i mean why would
doom
is because he's after vibranium i think
is that what the theory stands yeah i
don't know the trailers make it look
like that namor has a real personal
issue yeah it does this is like a person
and i feel like that would
i wouldn't like that if if if you
somehow manipulated the situation
into them fighting each other if it's a
geopolitical thing because it's like
seeing all those soldiers made me think
that you know
they're they're messing with wakanda and
and atlantis and i feel like part of
this is the repercussions of opening and
revealing wakanda to the world now
you're gonna have more people poaching
and running these operations so to me it
seems like there is a down-to-earth
motivation for that you could at least
glean from the trailer but yeah if
doctor doom has some kind of like this
is
one bullet point of a bigger array of
things like if it was just doctor doom
and he's like this is my main priority
is this story here of black panther 2.
it might seem a little random i guess
yeah or a little too much at once and it
would take away from all the other [ __ ]
they have to introduce in this movie and
i feel like a movie that's also a
memorium
i don't know i feel like doctor do might
overshadow that
john's word of the day geopolitical
that's right yeah that's right yeah i
think if there's not a personal reason
for for neymar to attack then it just
under undercuts the whole thing
especially when you have killmonger
that's such a personal reason we should
make it gotta keep it personal we should
make a name or shirt where it's just him
and aquaman going
yeah third awkward third third aqua guy
yeah what's what's the knock off of both
of those uh flounder uh the deep we'll
put the deep on that deep oh it's deep
yeah it's not a bad shirt idea hey
three three aquaman that's not bad
we'll write it out it could be in water
yeah
pointing
pointing it'll have little bubbles
around don't forget that and the deep
will have an octopus on his junk
do you think they'll kill neymar and uh
i don't think they're gonna kill name
more
i i don't i don't think he's too
important of a character name or the
submariner
you never know they killed iron monger
damn it everyone's been wanting jeff
bridges to come back box of scraps
john martin hey rejects big fan from
florida the guy from rick and morty
would be a good one or the guy from the
[ __ ] uh
gravity falls oh
no the guy from rick and morty the
latest season one of the latest seasons
the the rick's rick's uh arch nemesis oh
well i'm way ahead on rick and morty
than you are aren't they yeah i'm sorry
um
no the uh voice is a special voice i
don't know what the voice is but it's
it's rick's arch nemesis and he's he's
he's more yeah i want to see that yeah
uh
john martin
hey real read john martin hey cool um
hey real rejects big fan from florida oh
i'm not a big fan of the floor man i'm
not gonna go to florida whatever florida
man what marvel property would be good
for a keanu reeves and donnie yen
combination dude [ __ ] chongchi too
it really would be oh my god because
then you could have you could have keanu
be like the one white guy who's involved
in all this you know combat stuff yeah
he controls the police that's the
character from rick and morty yes
he controls the police
there's a whole thing with the character
here
i'm excited to meet this i i i i i've
never been more excited to not know what
you guys are talking about
um but yeah that would be perfect for
chongqi oh my god i mean donnie yen it
would seem like would be a shoo-in at
some point to be in that franchise in
some way shape or form but also you know
keanu reeves would absolutely fit in
yeah i mean the thing is
you would
there are other characters that seem
more long-lasting that you would have
keanu reeves play so it could be iron
fist why not
i am the immortal iron
[Laughter]
i'm danny ray
i'm danny
uh yeah fish flit flish person
flish person
is that it
i'm gonna i'm gonna watch the show don't
worry guys i'm gonna catch up it's gonna
be awesome anyhow thank you john martin
isn't there a liam neeson movie
character called john martin yeah and
namor is um
some consider namor to be
the first mutant
ah
he's an alpha mutant yeah he's got all
the powers he's got so much power
and so many superhuman things jordan von
doom oh welcome back
i want javier bardema's doom more than
anything else also you're all excited to
see adam warlock on screen someone hope
he has a bigger part in future films i
really hope so too i mean even we just
did phase one through three and you know
the infinity gauntlet com and if they
had adam warlock was very instrumental
in that
and was completely excluded from
all the fun stuff there in phase one
through three so yeah i don't think adam
warlock is gonna beat the death of him
here unless james gunn does one of those
things where he's like i'm gonna kill a
bunch of characters for fun um but no
adam warlock i think is is a character
that has to stick around for a while and
so yeah i would absolutely i i'm very
excited to see adam warlock do it i'm
very curious to see what will poulter's
take is going to be
i'm very curious i like what is james
gunn rendition gonna be of adam warlock
he's gonna try to honor it to be very
comic accurate or will it be
funny
i don't know
but i would love to see adam warlock and
dr strange interact with each other down
the road that's a big one that i really
want
and i want to see adam warlock a bit on
the nuts it's cause like they
you know like phase six uh
there's several open slots but like i
said i think supernatural
time is gonna be phase seven through
nine
and because you know doctor strange ends
in a way we're like we clearly got a
plan for doctor strange three
yeah where's that is that that is that
gonna be in phase six
yeah it seems like they would make the
most sense for that phoenix
bird gaming who do you guys see
directing new avengers movies
like what directors can transfer over
like i don't think they just mean in
secret wars yeah
king dynasty but i think they can dire
who would be a good i would like to see
the daniels do it but i just wanted to
be held back the people did everything
everywhere all at once
i feel like we should look at the
current slate of who's directing these
things then
uh who who are the ones who directed
game night they actually directed the
dungeons and dragons movie was that john
francis daly and his partner or am i
thinking of something else
yeah i think they wrote didn't they
write on the spider-man movies no no no
no no am i wrong about that
but yeah the ones who directed like game
night i thought did an excellent job
francis daley i don't know
um i mean if we're going by the past um
julius ona but i don't think he will get
the the avengers gig
and i don't think it'll be james
i think kerry fukunaqua
that could be could be a great director
for marvel he yeah if they could play
ball with him yeah and uh you know he
directed an episode a couple episodes of
the mandalorian that i thought he did an
excellent job i think bryce anyone from
who worked on
the mandalorian and boba fett
yeah say rick family you uh yes dallas
howard the rucho
although oh no it was rick family you uh
yeah who did uh who did mandalorian
who did i say well bryce did mandalorian
too but who was the other person i said
yeah yeah no rick uh who's the one sorry
guys goddamn names
yeah yeah uh i think he'd be good and
bryce toss howard i think would be a
great pick too to direct some event to
to work on something duffer bros bros as
chief ed singer would be a good time but
i think i think duffer brothers should
probably do one of their shows
alfonso quran could probably do
something really interesting if they let
him do it the way he'd want alfonso
caron should direct uh eternals too
that's not a bad pick it's not that's
not a bad pick at all because
you'll have the same amount of natural
light but you'll probably have at least
a bit more of a spectacle-oriented
bonzo knows how to do action man yeah
he's a great action like he's a great
director he knows how to do the drama
and his long ass shots and
one takes but he knows how to do action
extremely well oh yeah children of men's
action scenes are awesome uh [ __ ]
revenant
yeah he would be great del toro would be
a great pick for the future too did he
do gravity yeah not robert maybe not rob
rodriguez
but the other directors of the other
episodes are [ __ ] great if rodriguez
did some of the hell stuff i would be on
board for that i would be on board
that's true i mean there were there was
a one moment in doctor strange that
always makes me think of rob rodriguez
and i like the moment too
where's my where's our stuff oh
it's in the other window we still have 2
000 viewers my god golly live for a
while
who who were we talking about before
robert rodriguez
i don't know uh i had a thing
now it's gone all right um hey carbon
outlaw keanu reeves is dracula
that's uh no please don't blue inferno
what is the [ __ ] that it was in the
dracula movie yeah
gary oldman to play dracula yeah i've
never actually fully seen bram stoker's
dracula i just know that one thing with
uh his british accent would it be a good
reaction
there are reactions with a lot of uh
views
and halloween's coming
do you love sports i've never seen that
movie either really never seen dracula
we could do bs dracula a lot of behind
the scenes on dracula of them not
getting along carry over
my main association we could do that
lost boys
guy richie for ghost rider actually
wouldn't be a bad people cool after he's
done it you could show
you could show you they've
yeah the guy knows how to just uh you
know [ __ ] you know get his paycheck
he doesn't know how to get that paper
[Laughter]
dominic perez
i don't know if you saw nope but the guy
who plays the electrician says he wants
to play nova in the mcu and i'm honestly
not against it and nova will always be
my most anticipated mcu i'm not sure
no you're not about this
you don't i who's
i don't want to look up who the
electrician is afraid of spoilers i
don't want to see anything about no i've
avoided every trailer since the first
one ever since freaking um
who played shangchi
see me
yeah ever since him putting it out there
that he want he wanted to play chongqi
yeah and it came to life now his actress
thing just put it out there and get
roles i'm gonna tweet this
audition like everyone else wait for
that call from feige yeah wait for kevin
to show up at your house earn your way
don't just tweet for it wait for the
marvel chopper to land on your roof i'll
tell you how to get big work
oh goodness yes siree bob i do think
mephisto could be the big bad for seven
through nine easy
totally yeah con
con will kang dynasty be like infinity
war to secret wars and i think they're
gonna do something structurally
different i think they
are probably well aware we're expecting
like okay so we're gonna lose in the
first half and win in the second half
but i feel like they'll do something
more interesting than that well i think
kane can create such [ __ ] ups in kang
dynasty and dr doom steps in to save it
and that's how he creates
something like a battle world yeah so
it's like we get that portent of like
okay doctor doom is here i'm a hero no
that's not going to be good in the long
run but for right now yeah it's like oh
salvation is going well a lot of there's
a lot of times with doctor doom he's
he's a baddie but there's a lot of times
we're like look this planet this this
threat is so bad we we need doctor
doom's help yeah there's only one guy to
turn to yeah and dr doom gets involved
but he can be cunning and he can get in
the he can uh
he can find a way to make this work to
his own personal gain
absolutely
so well and that's what makes him an
interesting character that's i i could
that would be an interesting twist
on the dynamics yeah that in order to
stop him then he dooms help but then
dooms but then you're actually saying
i'm doomed to be the big baddie
they shouldn't have revealed both titles
yeah i guess so it would have been cool
if they said avengers the king dynasty
and then avengers question mark question
mark question mark and then untitled
avengers movie hey and they should just
be like we know what the title is we're
just not telling you we should put it up
avengers working title
jordan von doom fantum it's really
between shannon and bartom uh bardem uh
javier bardem for uh for me for doom
into their their best contenders big
question is when will we get galactus
and who can blame again i'm saying james
spader john malkovich's galactus i think
the guy who played the electrician and
nope who should play nova should also
play galactus and and then i think we
should get um who would be a good
galactus
um
who's got a really good strong ch like
jawbone mel gibson mel would be
a good with his crazy
colonel xander's beard
why would we be disappointed that you're
still here i forgot that we're still
alive
i mean i i forgot how long we've been
live now i forgot we're still alive
no
you know it's thank you for being here
i'm not i'm not upset anymore i forgive
you for being here and i embrace it 3l
demon
we should probably turn i got i got
therapy
we should turn these supers off three
out we'll read off three l damon do you
think they'll introduce
majia and mr negative's inner demons in
daredevil as competitors to kingpin and
get to see kingpin's organization go to
war against his rival crime syndicates
that is true you could be building up
like a the thing is you got these two
parts of the mcu it seems like they're
doing were
very sci-fi and and you know cosmic and
and all this multiverse and all this
crazy [ __ ] and then you got this other
side where you're gonna get [ __ ] like
echo and daredevil these very ground
level heroes
and and then you got captain america new
world order which i feel like will be
you know a little bit more grounded and
more in the the trenches in the real
world
so you do gotta sort of build that up
and create some type of hybrid perhaps
so by having like mr negative come in
there because even like daredevil the
netflix show introduced the hand which
had carrot ninjas that could [ __ ]
like operate without having hearts you
know so they would have supernatural
qualities they had the resurrection of
elektra you know
and and then you had like luke cage
who's the superhero like daredevil
himself has a super human thing about it
which is the the vibe is very grounded
so i think
uh what i'm curious to see is like if
they are gonna keep the street level
stuff going will that somehow
circle into stuff like king dynasty or
secret wars because what you're talking
about here does sound like a really cool
show having rival crime syndicates and
you and if you are going to build
something up like that where there is a
war happening in the streets 18 episodes
suddenly sounds a lot more justified to
me for your daredevil show a crime song
for a first show where already those two
characters are going to be in the echo
series yeah
yeah
i think i saw somebody called out
stallone in the chat i think that would
be a good galactus
all right well i feel like you found it
you know
but having mr negative show up would be
great though i think mr positive is who
we really need that's that time of the
live stream
this is the juxtaposition dad jokes are
coming ian boomin
where do you think doctor strange fits
in all this he's gonna be trying to stop
these mad incursion events that he
helped bring upon us and then he's gonna
try and probably fail
uh he and clea out there in the
multiverse
i think i think there will be a strange
that's what i wonder is will there be a
strange film in phase six or is there
just gonna be it seems like that thing
with clia is setting up for another film
uh but it could just be that we're gonna
see a lot of them moving through the
multiverse but i feel like they gotta
show back up in a big way before all the
incursions hit i think you know instead
of the next time we see doctor strange
that it's not going to be oh doctor
strange is here
i mean another doctor strange movie
well take two
okay i think the next time we see
dr strange
there's going to be a time jump and and
some of the journey has already happened
with him and clea sure yeah versus
picking up exactly where we left off
you mean like the time jump between the
end of doctor strange 2 and the
post-credits scene of doctor
there'd be another another time jump
he's got four eyes on his forehead
um but yeah that would make sense yeah
they've been out doing this for a while
and the situation has gotten worse in
the time that we haven't seen them so
now they're probably more battled uh
battered and and battle worn together
yeah you can't use sylvester stallone
he's already in guardians of the galaxy
i knew that when i said it
leviticus
or iron fist have you heard about this
new cut of rocky iv that stallone did i
heard it's great i heard it's great it's
like an actual real movie
yeah hey um deadshot deadshot bp2 should
end with t'challa and ancestral plane
i don't think they should do any like
cgi
fake [ __ ] with
chadwick boseman to be honest i think
the murals are good enough um
yeah i don't want that
i want that and
yeah
it's weird i mean this is the problem is
is with this is when it becomes i think
very real for people when it's like they
resurrected peter cushing for that star
wars uh for for rogue one it's you know
far removed from a lot of people but
like chadwick boseman i feel like a lot
of people might think that a little
unnerving and maybe not quite respectful
not that you know i mean he was clearly
on board and clearly was prepping to do
the movie so i'm sure he would have
happily said like yeah if you need to
use my likeness go ahead sure um but
yeah
brian cranston as glad this would be
cool oh which house is in the mcu that
would be big maybe to me
that would be interesting it would have
to be the exact right mcu property for
them and they would have to also be able
to go and get wild thai long kicks i
believe
marvel should bring in a new t'challa
through the multiverse that way you are
honoring chadwick without killing off
t'challa for good
maybe i i feel like it is a struggle
actually that's a great way to ha that
is a great way to bring in another
t'challa sure if there's a way to make
it work surely
and
um
yeah i mean the fact that recast the
troll is still going around even though
the trailers are clearly showing you
that's sichua died yeah in this universe
you know but that is that's a great way
to do it i wouldn't be opposed to that
at all i feel like in this movie at
least here and now it's a more powerful
statement to hand the mantle to somebody
else
however it would be cool to get another
t'challa from the multiverse mel gibson
is t'challa thank you
that's the one that's what we need
uh hey
stefan
anastasov and
uh it's just amazing to hang out with
you guys thank you it's amazing to hang
out with you stephen do you think
spiderman will be dripping with the
symbiote suit in secret awards
ooh that could be cool
that actually would be perfect time for
him to you imagine that's the no i i
think i think they got to do the
symbiote suit
proper justice like if you guys haven't
seen
spectacular spider-man
there's a great story arc there with
the
with the c and it's on netflix now in in
the states at least
um
but the the they did a great symbiote
storyline of that was like what
spider-man 3 with toby wanted to do but
didn't quite know
they nailed it in uh spectacular
spider-man and and i would like to see a
version of that
like not him just fighting venom right
away in the first movie
um but
truly just focused on
all the darkness within peter parker
that is slowly overtaking him yeah that
would be a great time to use the
symbiote suit yeah
but
you know seeing it being rocked honoring
secret wars
i'd be down it would be sick it would be
a bit down somebody said matthew vaughn
in the in the chat and i thought of
matthew vaughn to direct this black suit
spider-man movie and that would be cool
actually that actually would be a good
pick yeah right
now
anyone curious these live streams are
too long i already shot a town and
watched you guys for three hours what
the [ __ ] else you gotta do what do you
have going on in your life what's you
gotta do who are you just gonna listen
all right so watch you don't even have
to be at the screen talking yeah jesus
we don't need you
to speak you know it's okay that's a
vlog that goes
anyone curious where moon knight will
factor into all this maybe he could be a
part of the thunderbolts team as jake
lockley
uh
interesting i hadn't thought that would
be so cool cool if they announced
thunderbolts cast because kevin feige
said more on the cast to come later they
announced the d23 the lineup and moon
night is part of it i'm pretty sure
they're reserving him for for the
midnight suns yeah however
i do think that they would be a per i do
think
moon knight in in thunderbolts would
actually work that would be sick it
would be really cool yeah it's like i
hear thunderballs and my natural
reaction is something a little more
close to the ground but but but yeah
like having him as the sort of super one
of the supernatural members that would
be suck
sora
2ko5 2 2005
i would love to see rouge that's what i
was saying earlier yeah see rogue in the
marvels in which she steals captain
marvel's powers just yeah
that's exactly i was just talking about
that earlier bring back i don't think
it's going to happen though
i i don't think it's gonna happen bring
back when the pack win
i think it's gonna happen i'm sure of it
in fact you heard it here official leak
i saved your life i saved your life
that's my
that's my um we do have a podcast we
have real rejections actually it's gonna
be re-uploaded this is super the podcast
it's gonna take a long time to download
but it's gonna be up there um michael
mack
hear me out hurry up joel kidman
as doom i like joel kinnaman i do i like
scott eastwood
that's we like joel kidd a minute we've
gotta do it here yeah and anybody who
doesn't can get out
uh i like joel kinnaman i don't know if
i
i could i mean i'm sure i would enjoy
his turn as doom when i wave my metal
detector over it it doesn't go off yes
simon cowell absolutely should be the
thing specifically literally james is
rogue he's not a bad pick either no uh
uh bonna de armas is rogue yes
anna de armas is every character canada
almost a storm yes that's not
problematic
as all the x-men all of them
seems like women do all the work around
here she'd consider changing the name to
x-woman x-women
that was such a progressive line yeah
before it's time written by simon
kinberg
directed by simon
hey man you know men should really be
telling women stories
in the writing and directing phase and
somehow jessica chastain was like yo you
should direct my next movie
you know how to capture a
must like working with him
rtc rockstar hello i love scotty's love
for scott eastwood in the chat hey
rtc rockstar hey love your videos guys
you're the most entertaining channel on
youtube
never leave well we'll leave when
youtube leaves we won't leave because
this is a live stream it's impossible
this live stream will stay on youtube
we don't delete them we're not jaby
coway we're not coward jabba's kablavis
is always powerful speaking out of turn
and no we're not gonna clip this [ __ ]
the way campia does because he has
structure to his live streams
good at promoting them via easily
uploadable segments
um
so a cinematic goodness
thank you rick architecture that was
nice cinematic goodness thank you for
the super chat i hope this quiets people
who said the mcu's directionless yeah
[ __ ] that was just so irritating to
hear there
this is what i can go to my job and be
irritated and marvel
and these people not that did there
weren't any valid criticism to face for
though i like facebook we should really
trust kevin's hindsight i trust kevin i
do i trust the kevin man um kevin's he's
got it i remember i remember actually
being on campia's stream above when when
uh
right around the time loki was airing or
had just finished airing
and and the question was brought up it's
like marvel doing too much and i was i
argued that like no i think they know
what they're doing and and it's like
they're creating
they've
marvel's done something very unique
something extremely unique they've
created marvel studios yeah so it's a
it's literally a film studio
dedicated to one
franchise it is you know like
versus there they want to be warner
brother there's like warner brothers and
then there's universal and and in in any
all the other studios have multiple
movies and multiple franchises and
marvel studios to me it's never
registers too much
just to it's like would you be like
warner brothers you're putting out too
many too many
too much
one movie a year wb maybe two or three
that's it and i think that's where my
mentality worked is like no it's marvel
studios it's just a one studio dedicated
as one [ __ ] franchise yeah it's not
it's versus like there's the dc
department for for warner brothers
you know
this is um
this is it's just a different experience
so yeah i mean it's like they have their
hits phase one through three wasn't
perfect guys you had [ __ ] that just
[ __ ] was not that good and there's
something about the marvel phases as
opposed to something like lucasfilm and
star wars where like they make star wars
and it's all kind of unified by a tone
and and a style people expect whereas
the m7 and also star wars is and same
thing like when i see the lord of the
rings trailers they're all like [ __ ]
around like the [ __ ] around one the
goddamn ring
star wars you know the the one more oh
yeah stemming off of the one few things
the most important core elements that
you're familiar with whereas the mcu is
unique in that
i mean yeah you need to see all of them
to get the big picture but each
franchise has a slightly different uh
genre it's aiming for a slightly
different audience it's encompassing and
i think that they have
have conceived this in a way where it's
okay for you not to love every single
one i don't think they need you to do
that i don't think that every like yes
you want every property to be great and
incredibly well made but i feel like of
course part of the point is that
everyone's gonna have different
favorites and that's all going to come
together into a lively experience where
like yeah you might like the cosmic side
more or the down to earth side more and
you know with like yeah all these other
franchises you don't so much get that so
it's like even though marvel studios is
dedicated to one franchise it's also got
like a bunch of sub franchises within
that franchise that have different
flavors and stuff
actually
she she is going to be in um
she is going to be
in uh
enough camo is going to be in scrims she
is
yeah i hope so
uh emodo who would you cast the four
bane x-men easy easy peasy watch this
watch it happen joe
professor x
oh does that uh yeah yeah he's the main
x-men he's the ex
cyclops i i say um
uh glenn powell
and uh and then uh
[ __ ]
wait who are the four main x-men yeah
yeah are we going like magneto professor
x wolverine and cyclops or yeah
yeah you know and uh and yeah like a
gambit or uh
or i love i like the choices as austin
butler as gambit yeah i did too or let's
just give freaking patch or they should
give a chance to hit him a shot yeah
remember that
um i want to hear his case i actually
thought oscar isaac would have been a
perfect wolverine but that was our moon
knight i know
that's a hard roll to fill wolverine it
is a really hard roll can you imagine
having to [ __ ] take up that mantle
danny devito is the only one who could
do it you were right
or mike myers or mike
oh
all that makeup
bronson plays hey
i'm y'alls 1 million stream you said
that y'all could react to our short film
on our family films youtube we sent the
link to instagram so we did thanks
find that link john have to go check a
look at the link find the link all right
we're doing it we're doing the link
screenshot andrew davison
daredevil oh yeah yeah
yeah
oh yeah daredevil oh yeah dd i agree
daredevil oh oh yeah amazon gives us a
lot of you know you know it really sucks
when you put in like a couple hours to
like two two three hours of putting [ __ ]
together for a video
and then suddenly amazon's like we're
blocking you on mobile right away and we
won't lift this claim for like three
days
uh it's a real [ __ ] annoying thing so
there's just some things weirdly though
when we cover the shows we don't really
deal with that [ __ ]
dude
ryan gosling apparently wants to play
ghost rider and he's not playing nova
confirmed barooz
jump let's focus
link i'm not gonna do that now we bruce
what would be fantastic if you guys
upgrade to 4k streaming love the show
and you guys will get the 4k streaming
going john
oh you could probably do that in the
next one yeah yeah man i'll find a way
what's taking you so long let me see if
i can do it right now and crash this
there's probably a way to update some of
this but uh but yeah
you want to watch us in that high of a
definition i i like that you don't want
to man i'm glad oh kiki palmer as storm
that would be a great choice actually
yeah she's great she's like the greatest
person in the world or whatever she just
tweeted she's about herself she's
[ __ ] great
yeah terrific we start at the light year
premiere she's awesome
and tiffany haddish is at every premiere
i know tiffany has just a big random
premiere yeah
a disney fan i guess
giant again love oh thank you guys thank
you gal
i love your hair tom cruise is dr doom
yes arnold vosney who is dr doom yes
justice for arnold vaslu
jordan von doom dad son why are you
crying son
in the clay face void do your best
clayface voice and read that
they've clashed
lady gaga's doctor doom
[Laughter]
it's like he's here in the room
i remember what clayface sounds like
that's
as good as what i would have done
uh yeah lady gaga when she is going to
join the mcu there's got to be a role
for lady gaga dude [ __ ] storm [ __ ]
storm
storm the one she is the african
princess lady gaga is an amazing actress
she's good at listening and responding
yeah
yeah she can do lines too she's a great
actress
she's a great actress yeah oh rested
he's britney murphy loves her work in
american horror story loved her work and
star was born loved her work in um
that [ __ ] not that good of a movie
but she's good how's it gucci she's good
this is good
you can count to gucci man house of
gooch no john carl esposito not as
magneto professor x professor sex i
don't want him playing ready for phil
there's no more villains they all feel
like a variant of gust-free they are all
a variant of gus frank we'll go we want
a gus type they're all like they're
slightly different
i can distinguish them from gusfering
but they all feel like
just a a different version of gus you
know the flavors that made such
do exactly that
like gus fring is much more
um
stoic and
and just like rage internalized you know
and puts up such a front where unlike
moff gideon
but moff gideon is more monologuey yeah
true you know he's less internalized
yeah lording over people yeah like
there's like slight differences standing
bitter is very charismatic but it's
still
they're still
you they're all being cast because you
played [ __ ] gus and breaking bad yeah
all right
i'm sick of it
i'm sick of it it's like so good every
time but i'm like it's still gusting liv
schreiber's jubilee absolutely pedro
pascal for beast not a bad choice john
cena as sabretooth nifra says omega red
earthing i don't know about that
i think john cena has to john cena's had
its strength when he does something that
has a comedic slant to it yes do we do
fan mail we have a p.o box
far away we don't go to it that often
we're not even waiting for you we need
to move through the field box here yeah
i'll go ahead far away
i'll go pick up the last package and
shut it down and then we'll find a new
place to have a po bugs loki variant i
don't think you're the only one who
doesn't really care for mohawk it's not
that big of a talk
yeah
the hit show on hulu is
oh my god do we oh my god no there's
more i thought i was like to the top
we're getting there all right here's
what i'm gonna do we're gonna make sure
we're because we gotta
greggy's got therapy
greggy's got to talk about life
i gotta be like someone said some mean
[ __ ] to me in my stream doc
now i don't know how to be myself who am
i after years of doing this i still
haven't learned how to handle a negative
commonly i don't i don't know what i'm
doing man oh you'll have to pull the
window up yeah no it happens john you
happened see i think john cena would be
a good version of the thing and i like
the rumor of jason siegel playing i
think jason sequel is an unexpected
choice and could totally work and at the
end of the day that role is going to
mainly rely what the [ __ ] wrong with
warren he knows i'm on a live stream
warren needs to speak whenever he needs
to speak it's just the way of life
hey warren answer it
no
you can't be on the live stream right
now in the future i'll find the the
service we can use we're actually you in
as a we're actually trying to
wrap up the live stream because i got a
therapy appointment to get to and i want
to make sure i make it in time
not screw mental health
next i mean you would be perfect i
shouted out your your your breakdown at
the beginning of the stream as
i think you did the best one out of the
i actually listened to a bunch of the
announcement videos and i really think
you did the best one man i think the
chat is getting delirious i saw joe
bidden as mr talking i'm talking to
cosmic wonder right now put him on
speaker he's got massive leaks he wants
to report and i'm telling him not to do
it
i i just provided he got the avengers
leaks and i said don't you dare post
that [ __ ] warren
because because kevin feige told me that
he'll shoot you in the face
yes he is the sniper on speed dial
warren
all right man
i need to wrap this up but i'm glad you
could be the center of attention for for
one minute this is a fake phone call i'm
having on the stream by the way guys
and it probably wouldn't pick up say hi
to the stream cosmic wonder
[Music]
we will figure out how to patch phone
calls in that's the thing we can
theoretically do so in the future we'll
figure it out all right but hi we're
gonna talk with you soon keep killing
your videos let's see how great they're
doing when's your next cover coming out
don't ask him questions because he's
gonna stay on the phone we need to get
off the phones
all righty beirus
[Music]
is back also for she-hulk breaking the
fourth wall took me out and personally
for me not believable
and doesn't make sense in this world
makes sense more for deadpool deadpool
isn't the only person with the fourth
one doesn't she hulk break the fourth
wall it does in the comics she does that
happened before deadpool was even
introduced i don't know about that but i
do i thought i heard i know she breaks
it they're just woking up deadpool uh
it's war and time it's our fans
one day we will figure out how to like
actually call people in no i can't just
go with a therapy i have an appointment
for therapy you know if we if we end at
a certain point i will make it on time
yeah and if we don't then you can't just
be like all right
wait for you all day what's going on hey
everybody i've just been sitting here
no other clients to talk to dakota jones
hey one virus effects what's up what
canada forever will be a healing session
for a lot who are grieving i'm so
excited for daredevil i hope to see
bullseye back love you guys love you too
dakota
incredible incredible citizen of the
reject nation and yeah i think that's
the main goal for wakanda forever it
became about something much more
meaningful and
i am i
i do want to see bullseye come back
i do want to see bullseye come back home
it's like if you're going to be bringing
it back you should bring it back you
know what i mean
like
i don't know if you i don't know if you
know what if you like you should
actually
bring the season three portrayal yeah
but it's going to be different i mean we
see daredevil has like a brand new suit
with uh
it's like the red and yellow suit yeah i
i'm not 100 on it yet no i have to see a
full body shot yeah i'd have to see a
full body shot and see it in motion i
mean to me [ __ ] charlie cox always
looked the best in the goddamn just all
black the black with the the bandana
yeah like where's don't don't i have the
funko i think it's right there
yeah it's right here
yeah it's on the top road you know like
the all black
black everything yeah yeah it's just
just like the simplest you know because
there's something mysterious where's
like it's just his eyes are covered
yeah it's so because he doesn't need a
seat
and it gives his face this cool bird
like you know look when he when he's
that way also just david should be in
the mcu let's make that oh my god we're
not even showing this on the screen oh
snapple
do y'all mixed man do you all think
deadpool 3 will be more of an mcu
deadpool origin or pickup or deadpool
tesla oh definitely more of a deadpool 3
mcu i don't even think you're gonna call
it deadpool three
they'll probably yeah they'll call it
deadpool joins the marvel universe yeah
i think they would probably have it be a
subtitle that would still be like a
deadpool 3
but it would uh
but it but i don't think they're going
to call it deadpool 3.
what would they call it probably just
deadpool joins the marvel cinematic
something like that deadpool and this
great deadpool breaks the wall of the
marvel cinematic yeah
deadpool in the mcu for make benefit
great corporation of disney
sora 2ko5 i think neymar is still going
to be immune in an mcu he has the wings
on his feet which in the comics gives
them the ability to fly i think the fact
that they have put out miss marvel
beforehand introducing mutation
they could very well keep namor as a
mutant and uh frankly they oughta they
ought to keep him as two for sure quit
quit not giving us mutants that are not
that don't end up being mutants you know
what i mean
like scarlet witch are they gonna
confirm this world which is a mutant or
not are they going to [ __ ] do that or
not
what are they going to do
deadpool kills the mcu would be it will
be a [ __ ] gripping title that's to
say sure like what are they going to do
it deadpool finally home potomac
kaczynski
ricky diaz hi y'all this is haley
steinfeld's future husband
i like these things i love these
deadpool titles y'all are coming up with
i will predict that the atlantis and
wakanda conflict is caused by doctor
doom and his men messing around
underwater may be defined vibranium
i think that's uh there's there's shades
of that that could happen
i don't know if it would be exactly a
hundred percent just that but it could
be a part of it
okay so the the implications that the
wakanda people are looking for it and
then they they they find
wait wait i'm kind of confused by this
theory i'll probably the atlantis and
mcconnell conflict is caused by doctor
doom and his men messing around
underwater oh that dr doom is the one
who sent that he needs to make his
vibranium and he's going to think that
it has something to do with
the landings you're going to think it
has some that the atlanteans are going
to think that is what conda you know
honing in well i'm thinking it might
have something to do with riri williams
that would make sense too because
they're bringing she built those
submersible suits in here purposefully
yeah yeah and she's like an explorers or
something i feel like it has something
to do with her like there's a reason
she's here yeah
and featured not just enough to be
featured in the trailer yeah
um
um
john
shield vids would you guys watch a what
if with agents of shield or netflix
characters interacting in mc yes
absolutely i would there's so many
characters i would love to see i mean i
i think it would be just finished agency
i did just finish agents of shield come
over to patreon and watch it with me it
was a very fun and emotional experience
um and i would i mean i would love to
see colson come back
post like in in a way uh
that even if it's a what if in a way
that acknowledges agents of shield
somehow i feel like
because of yeah
because of uh
i think because of the fact that you
know like the history of uh in humans
versus mutants and the whole like the
idea that that was like a legal issue
i feel like in humans may not be very
heavily incorporated into the main mcu
because the fact that they now have
mutants which was always their intent
you know
the inhumans were created partly due to
issues of rights and things like that um
so
part of me doesn't expect it fully but i
would love to see it
love to see it bring quake back ig
cabazone thank you for the super chat i
believe the music will play more of the
ant-man role by not being in kang
dynasty and finally come and seek your
wars to save the day it's not it won't
be injured on your left
it's all the experts yeah
it's that x-men wallpaper
it's all standing
right yeah all of us are all posing in
the right spots it's like a video game
character
uh no theme plays it'll be great
see i wonder if they're gonna make x-men
97 canon in some way i could
i could see it that's my big question
i mean it seems like it would conflict
because then that would have to mean
that x-men the animated series is canon
and then that would have to mean that
the x-men have just been around and no
one knows all right let's say explain
some [ __ ] with king
i heard a cool theory about kang
removing the mutants from the time mcu
timeline and that's why we don't know
about him
that's cool so he he was like no i'm
gonna put you on the fox timeline yeah
i mean i'm still going to keep the
fantastic four the humans and the
mutants on earth eight three eight foot
scarlet witch we're just gonna have you
know some uh we're gonna pull some
strings into how this all works why
don't you watch new rockstars breakdown
but it was [ __ ] so busy for the past
couple months and that's that's
other stuff to do yeah yeah
so people think they'd take like an hour
to put together
a while
you know
nolan s underscore it's been busy we got
koi now to do [ __ ] yeah he's yeah he's
he's our eric boss do you think century
could show up in phase six i think
anything's possible phase six um
let me see here
see do you sure sure why not yeah
[ __ ] spring and bring him in okay
century's coming nova is coming i'm not
that familiar with century to be honest
but yeah that would be a good way to do
it thank you nolan
john i've been holding the bathroom for
a long time go take a dump
who needs voss when you have a koi
exactly that's why we got the koi yeah
we got the comic corner
jordan von doom do y'all think ultron
will ever make a return
no
[Laughter]
i mean sure at some point not anytime
soon though not anytime soon i think uh
the
honest answer
probably not
i think i mean it was cool i liked uh
the what-if episodes that he was a big
part of and i think that was the big
ultron moment for the current moment
uh i think it'll take a while to have
another old i feel like they would need
to do another universe reset before we
get like a real ultron in in a big way
i mean they they already sort of brought
ultron back with what if yeah exactly
the big mo network james earl jones as
galactus need a powerful voice oh dude
they got that uh it would have been
great they got that ai james earl jones
now they can use which actually works
really well i know
maybe california
captain captain america shows that
and guardians of galaxies iii has nova
no i think noah's gonna be a little too
much regarding to the galaxy three i
think nova will eventually come they
already said they have a novo project in
development i thought that was a real
thing that was announced was it not i
thought so that was like that was
reported in the trade developing it and
it's reported that ryan gosling is not
playing nova
yeah i don't think
people keep asking him and he said no um
but yeah i think i think no i think
thunderbolt i don't think you need to
show the thunderbolts prior to the
thunderbolts movie they're already
building up the thunderbolt so maybe
they'll have a character from captain
america new world order
who could then
make an appearance in thunderbolts yeah
you know what i mean yeah i know what
you mean
jordan von doom asks do you all think
the mcu will ever actually end no
there's a thing called marvel studios
they need to keep it alive forever
that'd be they have to shut down the
studios it'll keep changing but those
characters are not going anywhere as
long as eyebrows are a thing
yeah i think i think it's gonna stick
around forever and uh it's that's why
they got it they gotta they gotta keep
the rep the thing is that's just a lot
of pressure because you are it is just
one franchise you're focused on that's
right
john christopher oh no no yeah you got
the the mouse makes the little stickers
move oh cool christopher hyde thank you
for the cool ass like hippo guy here
thanks chris hyde doing like cool finger
jams tony tony that's how uh that's so
terrance howard says tony and iron man
one tony
tony hey man
uh corey whenever corey coleman does a
terence howard it makes me he's happy
inside
do you think we'll see jonathan majors
play iron lad and ant-man well thanks
for the question tony no i thought that
uh is it is it iron lad like a
adolescent version
yeah
right i don't know that's an adolescent
version of him with like
a cool like
metals
from a distance looks like an iron man
suit he's got a child actor and then put
jonathan major's head on his body
yeah and uh and do that weird thing no i
don't think we're going to see iron i
mean we can see atlanta like king
dynasty or down the road but i don't
think we're going to see king i don't
think we're going to see iron lad thomas
mania tom cruise iron lad
marco
i will go to the bathroom i promise i'll
take you all with me bring the camera
marco i do hope toby and andrew show up
in secret wars that would be badass yes
absolutely
uh there was no mention of nova yet in
phases five and six i wonder when or
where he'll appear also i want to see
howard the duck in secret wars by the
way love what you do guys citizen of the
reject nation ph represent whoo
ph water yeah
the the base versus acidity let's do
this i think howard the duck will make
his brilliant cameo perform i think he
should get a full on scene
with like rocket raccoon yes in in
guardians of the galaxy vol 3.
perfect i think you should give him a
real scene he hasn't gone in like a real
scene you know
looks like somebody can try
yeah yeah i think he should replace
rocket raccoon when rocket raccoon gets
killed off the guardians of the galaxy
three immediately
just get a new one off the off the
conveyor belt adam versus life what do
you think of melissa benios who played
supergirl as sue storm i think she'd be
great
she's an attractive woman with a lot of
talent and she's funny
but
i don't think they're gonna do i don't
think it's gonna be her i think they're
gonna do someone else who doesn't look
as traditional sue storm who could
keegan michael key play in the mcu oh he
could play reed richards yes yes silver
surf i could stretch
it
out
i didn't think i wanted to stretch but i
ended up liking stretching
you need it we need it nash sanodiki
what's up my dude
kang reminds me a bit of the thinker
from the flash
uh
yeah speaking of the thinker oh who
played the thinker in suicide squad
peter capaldi peter capaldi that's my
doom old ass dude
christine we are still live streaming
because when the questions are still
coming in we gotta honor all the
questions we got it we gotta i honor the
super chat they're like it just feels
like i'd be such a dick if i was like
all right i'll see you tomorrow you are
a penis
matthew jim norman reedus should be
ghost rider i think it would be cool
i don't know if he's my definitive
choice but i would be like yeah sure he
likes motorcycles
i feel like you know his love of
motorcycles is the main reason
you do that i got the grit it's norman
reedus that's true that's true he would
be good he would be good he'd be playing
norman reedus would be that's the same
way that's what i'm getting at the same
way paul rudd is
paul rudd yes
it's scott lake you know yeah it's like
not like
that's scott lane yeah that's ballroom i
always think
it's he's still in the back of you cool
yeah it's just buff paul rudd
ricky diaz i predict in king diamond
thank you ricky
kang will warn our heroes about doctor
doom and king will try to conquer them
and leads the secret wars and doctor
doom behind it wait a minute king will
warn our heroes about their doom and
king will try to conquer them
like i need to warn you guys about doom
so i'm going to conquer you guys
to protect you listen doctor doom is
coming but let me conquer let me just
give me the keys to planet earth
and uh you know i'll i'll make it all
better for you guys
uh yeah maybe
i did i did see that disney [ __ ]
the the
the thing with like falc
i just did it i i said captain america
uh
captain america miss marvel
and uh
captain marvel the disneyland thing
the ultron the people were like avengers
footage i'm like no it's just from the
ride
avengers campus i've never been
um so yeah
please don't swear language please
alto vote i'm going with voltage because
you got a lightning bolt in your in your
cool ass avatar now you guys look like
pilots with those headsets uh everyone
if you look at the left side of the live
stream you will see john campio still
streaming
and fasten up your seatbelts we are in
for i'll be right
i appreciate that super chat that's
probably the best one that was the best
one thank you doom is underwhelming
considering the flop fantastic four
movies that's why i'm saying you got to
build them up and not just put them in a
fantastic four movies where it just gets
[ __ ] defeated
and yes bob chap is rhino perfect
robertson vr any surprise death
candidates in phase five
i think
peter quill is gonna die yes that's
gonna happen i really think peter quill
is gonna gonna die
and and is gamora gonna come back
full time or are they both going to be
dead after guardians no gamora's going
to come back okay yeah she's going to be
great she's going to be the leader of
the guardians now uh i think um that's
cool oh vos drop the o'connor forever
trailer breakdown all right we're
leaving the stream
goodbye everybody everyone we're just
we're done
no woman no stream no uh live if we
started filming that now
we probably get that whole thing up in
about
yeah
uh surprise death candidates
john i got taken care of i already said
you said it you guys drax is definitely
dying too
that's a good call history i think he
wants out i think he wants it like
confirmed i'm gone
mano
mono in love mono in love thank you for
the moment of silence
as beautiful as the black panther 2
trailer was i'm still torn with the fact
that they chose not to recast t'challa
or have the sequel take place during the
blip when he was gone
rest uh recast t'challa hashtag and
hashtag variant t'challa i can see the
variant t'challa
i feel like a sequel said during the
blip where there's no t'challa would
just be a strange thing to have happen
here and now on this timeline um
that's the one thing i i i i do get
people's insistence on a recast in that
t'challa does is a really
significant character across the comics
and throughout the marvel universe
i
i don't know part of me says well you
know you you you
hand the black panther mantle off to the
next character and and we just go from
there and give them
whoever takes the mantle
the important events and moments that
would go to t'challa but at the same
time i get why
i get when people are like it's not the
same character
and it arguably should be like i feel
like it's it's there's no like right
answer that's gonna make everybody happy
unfortunately yeah yeah because then if
you did just recast a child then you
have a bunch of people pissed about
recasting
yeah and then two when he's in a no it's
a no-win situation yeah really and and
at this moment in time you know
once you get a little past it and people
don't have the immediate context you
would have a sort of i don't know i feel
like it would it would create
distraction
like there i think getting a variant to
charlo down the line is probably the
best option
yeah doing that later if if at all
could we see moonlight in the
post-credits scene for blade absolutely
for sure i think 100 stuff anytime you
see the moon you're seeing moon knight
uh christopher hyde so is ant-man the
most important hero in the ncu ant-man
is the reason why time travel became
possible and it'll introduce kang
that's wild that's what i mean i don't
think ant-man gets enough credit and i
feel like end game brought a lot of
credit his way
but you know like those ant-man
the standalone movies don't get enough
credit
and um
but the quantum realm is clearly
something that is massively important
to the development of the mcu so yeah
paul rudd man
all right that paul rudd
the only one who could
play other characters and people don't
go
scotland i know but you see those other
actors and other things you think of
their marvel counterparts that's right
even robert downey i still see him and
i'm like iron man
street of armor around the world
theodore harris
feige in an interview said he didn't
want to announce the thunderbolts team
right now as there are characters that
will be on the team that have not yet
that we have not uh yet encountered in
the mc no fascinating so we might not
even hear it at
you might not even hear
i mean if he wants to germinate some
hype do some [ __ ] like
we got do a cut out with like
silhouettes and then fill in the ones we
know about leave the other silhouettes
yeah and the question mark oh my god
that'd be brilliant who's that
thunderbolt yeah
nifferoos
love for you to do a review on weird
science
the 80s i appreciate this
problematic 80s the fact that you can
contribute a couple of dollars away it
makes me want to say yes but i got to
fall in my heart here and i don't i
don't think
i don't think we want to do that
i'm not sure we would want to do that
but if we change our minds we'll let you
know i don't know there are movies in
that vein i haven't seen we'll see mark
asked twine
john
what are your thoughts on nick offerman
as how would rip
ratchel racquel i would stretch my body
but mostly i choose to stretch out my
mustache
sue storm i must ask you to put some
clothes on god damn it
oh john you and your um thingies oh we
got a wise to go we got a few we got a
couple we watched this jump
dominic perez theory
the 23 will be used for announcements
for phase five but phase six info will
be revealed at a public event like what
they did the el capitan when infinity
war end game and other movies were
announced
okay what do you mean but i thought they
already
used a bunch of like just more specific
announcements on facebook no no they're
gonna tell us some of the blank spots in
phase six they got to tell us more more
video more movies that are coming they
got to tell us more movies
they're not enough movies there's not
enough movies
we need we need to hear something about
mutants please for the love of god tell
me something about the music tell me the
mutants series was real
i guess the
the thing with the phase four that feels
odd is that usually the the phases
end or close to the end have
a kind of culmination movie yeah a movie
that shows a culmination
and the fact that they're ending on
black panther wakanda forever not a
culmination movie nor is the movie
before it
that's the part that can be a little bit
strange i think for for for defining
this chapter yeah you know phase one is
avengers um you know phase two age of
ultron phase three infinity uh
spiderman or something
spider-man far from home is that what it
was
uh yeah um
i think it was far from home and i think
uh i think i think ant-man was man
first no i think i think mmm was phase
two ending something like that but
either way there was a culmination film
that brought brought it together yeah
and i think phase four doesn't have a
culmination film so
it's kind of the weird part i don't even
know if we probably answered your
question i appreciate that
jason davis hey guys do you change your
opinion of good movies after watching
pitch meetings
uh
no
no i mean yeah yeah yeah phase two was
ant-man yeah i think uh if any movie is
good enough like something like a pitch
meeting like is gonna make you go oh hi
that's a fair point but if it's you know
there's a certain amount of
height that goes into those where it's
like he'll bring up really good points
and criticisms but they're also
heightened for jest so yeah i've rarely
seen a pitch meeting and then gone
i don't like this movie anymore you know
yeah sometimes sometimes pitch meetings
can put into context though for
something well i didn't like it without
something sometimes i can't quite
pinpoint and pitch me so point it out
sharply
jason davis uh we just answered you
david lemon joseph quinn for mephisto
i don't mind that one at all
i don't mind it either he's gonna be in
there somewhere thanks for the super
chat yeah
junior
jr junior juniors junior
uh hey i got hi guys i'm a french guy hi
guys i'm a french guy who love your
video i
really enjoy all your videos you guys
are amazing kevin feige is a good bedue
uh and i hope you don't leave after that
terrible terrible day we just honored
his ass we just honored you you should
be thanking us
and also thank you guys for helping us
become a country but anyway um you know
i we love you out in france i i wish i
took more uh honestly if i end in ten
minutes i will make my therapy we got
this in ten minutes kevin feige is 2 30
ago so you got to like stop the super
test at certain point make sure you can
get through them mance 76 plays this was
probably one of the most excited things
this live stream or or the mcu
announcement oh definitely this live
stream the mcu announcements
they're always going to come with
you know how it goes
david and devin henderson
are they going to recast elektra
thoughts i certainly hope not i thought
she i certainly hope not
dark knight that's right
rachel's told me everything about you i
certainly hoped
a little patrick bateman in there um
that's who he's channeling in that scene
yeah rachel it's so good to see you
i want to rip out your guts and play
with your blood
they're going to recast a lecture
they're going to bring back jennifer
garner no
no not jennifer garner jesus christ the
electoral woman from the daredevil show
no jennifer garner from elections no
don't
uh who's the actor she played a lecturer
she was i don't know but she's bringing
her back beautiful and talented such a
haunting performance yes she's a real
martial artist
uh she's great she's awesome i i think
she's perfect as elektra and i i really
hope they keep her like she's a
just this dark soul you [ __ ] rooted
for who yeah couldn't help but kill she
was great and i i really hope they keep
her or they're recasting her with isaac
gonzales you know just as hot maybe not
as much depth
i'm here for it i'll take it tom thomas
thomas the ryan
jack ryan in season one episode 12 x-men
the phrase new world order is mentioned
potential link to captain america new
world order because mutants are here
definitely yes confirmed
she'll bring you back x-men 97 and they
could be using x-men 97 as a way because
they when they brought professor x into
when they brought first into doctor
strangelove's madness his his outfit
his wheelchair and all that was all you
know animated series inspired true that
so perhaps there is a way they're going
to bring back x-men 97 to explain what
happened to the mutants
and then maybe they encounter a kang in
there and then king is played by
jonathan majors and he comes back and
he's like the cgi animated
contrasting with the with the hand-drawn
animation
dude that would be really cool
do you listen to word i said contrast i
just i pictured i pitched terrible
things to you they're good i like them
all i don't i don't see the quality i
just see ideas
we're caught up here are we are we we
got gregor's doctor doom
yeah
[Music]
okay there's a few no there's some
there's god damn it john we gotta hustle
i know we gotta hustle that's what i'm
trying to do we gotta hustle gotta watch
the answers oh my gosh somehow i will
make it so we can
get a bunch of your labs until now
i'm gonna make my therapy you're gonna
make it we're going to we're going to do
it i'm going to show up stressed all
right
sure i can make fine left door just
arrived home turn on the stream and hear
you guys talking about dolphins
effing women huh i lol nevertheless
we're talking about uh the dolphin
hitler the dolphin hitler yes dolphin
hitler is now your new name uh dee uh
deshay is always appreciate that flip
dash is always watching i know you're
talking about the mcu but what did you
think of the chucky two trailer gotta
gotta watch it haven't seen it uh and
what did you i'm excited for it though
either way and what did you think of the
sandman trailer didn't see it didn't see
it i hear sandman's show based on a
comic i hope it's good it's hard to make
sand man if you saw them glad you guys
are feeling better thank you and uh the
addition of koi and sally has been
wonderful i'm so happy to hear that you
think so i appreciate that very much
yeah boy and sally are amazing
individuals sally is great
the great and powerful great and
powerful sally
back again one thing about captain
america new world order i love that
title mostly because it reminded me of
the famous 90s wrestling group nwo and
how i want one member of that group
kevin nash magic mike john wick play in
the mcu
love seeing you guys again bye kevin
nash mcu you're a [ __ ] great guy
you're a
flesh great man thank you just flavian i
know you want this spider-man chair so
bad it's not as comfortable as it man
you can come pick it up that's the
reason i don't really listen to it
i want a wolverine series for each
episode we get a different year leading
up to him meeting the x-men i think it's
a great way to establish him without
having to be in a team right away aka
thor of course did exactly what i wanted
to say there was a whole video there was
a video for you
yeah yeah it was a good idea and i need
i think it should happen that would be a
great way to do the origin tale
oh thanks you know thanks for the live
stream thanks for being here in the live
the live streams because of you live
people flippy
it's me again just wanted to say totally
relevant sometimes more than the movie
it's more heartbreaking to see greg
crying his watch alongs ha ha
keep him coming you two absolute legends
which john usually has been the major
crier lately i've been crying a lot i've
been crying loud movies lately but
john's usually the big crowd but you
can't just you can't just cry
at everything you know there's an
undercuts you're gonna then you just
become the guy who's crying at
everything yeah ever since this black
panther trailer now now i feel like i
gotta cry all the time
yeah you can't lose the mantle you can't
you got to get it back no i'm just
joking and then you'll finally start to
cry again when you realize you've lost
look at the movie reactions then the
playlist it's like
big laughing cry look at me crying
laughing crying
this is funny
hey floppy again
also i think the avengers movies uh
since they you got to read like koi come
on also i think for the avengers movies
if they come in a span of six months do
you know hello do you know like how
infinity war you had the earth story and
the titan planet story i feel like those
will be two separate avengers journeys
linking at the end of secret wars
agreed i that is what we've been saying
this whole time
i think that's a good solid theory thank
you for for throwing that in there
kieran
thank you for the momento di salencio
muchas gracias and a big old terry flap
big old terry flap hey greg and john
with the black panther 2 ending
p4 and ant-man 3 starting and p5 phase 5
that leaves guardians time crunch limbo
where does this go holiday special for
guardians take place in the timeline
christmas it's a holiday special is it
on the canon it's part of facebook it's
gonna be coming out in christmas yeah
it's a face it's it's it's it's a
holiday
november is is black panther and that's
the end of phase four they should
release it the same day as wakanda
forever that means the guardians of the
galaxy christmas special is just
drifting out in the middle of phase four
and five with no discernible phase to
call
do we announce when we go live usually
on uh community posts and and twitter i
forgot to do a story today i apologize
you racist
i'm not racist i know it was racist of
me to imply that you i cried during
shawshank redemption
that
is that white man went through a lot of
hard times through a lot of hard times
to get out of prison
uh hey this one
no we're caught up we got stickers to
shout out yeah
yes so we are all caught up hey kaden
finch hayden finch thank you for the
super chat sticky keep it up look at
that little work
way vera laughing pair that's a lovely
little pair that's amazing the richard
little coin guy love it thank you and
cameron scott little lemon guy with
heart we did it oh my god i'm gonna be
able to make my therapy and go to the
bathroom
it says red letter day at the reject
nation all right guys let's get it thank
you for everyone who contributed to
super chess let's get some quick shout
out names in here yes call me storm
shout out some stuff say bye to us so
we'll shout you out hey bucky barnes atl
thank you for moderating hey fan you're
rock zack bomb
did we let bucky barnes monitor we
didn't land bucky martin's moderators
he's got the wrench
he's a moderator
not moderator bucky barnes are the
monsters screw this up i must accept the
richard thank you for being
is doctor doom i can swallow it planet
no he should be
should be
playing
[Laughter]
galactus
michael peter b parker
[Music]
we gotta go but i appreciate everyone
for being here this was a really fun
stream wicket
um
this was super fun where
yeah this was great all right guys we're
gonna go take care say hi to everyone
that you love on behalf of us
and uh oh oh i'm autobots i'm gonna
leave roll out roll out autobots and
stream john all right we're downstream
we're finding the window that ends the
stream and we're gonna end the stream
for you guys bye reject nation we love
you so much
stay sexy
peace
yeah oh yes i'm sure i want to end this
i'm sure i'm sure youtube
come on